I already had a cold listen my hands are freezing I'm I'm I'm freezing and I'm wearing two shirts and and I put slacks on today so I don't know what's going on I just I feel like I'm out of sorts but I am never never too out of sorts to bring you guys an all-new smart list. Let's go. Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on. Oh, what's he doing? He's going potty potty he's going potty potty. He's taking a potty and he's taking a potty. Listener, we could have started on time but Will has got a child's bladder and what no he actually just came back in with two bottles of water. I guess he's a little dehydrated. No, I got one too.
我本来就感冒了，听着，我的手冰凉，我我我快冻僵了，我穿着两件衬衫，而且我今天穿了休闲裤，所以我不知道是怎么回事，我只是觉得自己有点不在状态，但我绝不会因为状态不好而错过给大家带来一期全新的 Smartless。我们开始吧。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。哦，他在干嘛？他在上厕所，他在上厕所。他在上厕所，他在上厕所。听众朋友们，我们本可以准时开始的，但威尔的膀胱像个小孩子一样，不对，他其实刚刚拿着两瓶水回来了。我想他有点脱水了。不，我也有一瓶。
So Will, you know, I got a little bit of grief listener for showing up 60 seconds late on our last session. You were three minutes late. Oh, sorry. Check that. What's what's what's the what's the math on that? That's three minutes. That's a hundred and so it's three times 180 180 180 seconds late. So I showed up early today and I said I said you know what the problem about showing up early is that you you risk seeing who the mystery guest is. And then what happened and our mystery guest, this guest accidentally bumped their camera cover and revealed and then I saw the guest was and I'm thrilled. I don't know. No, I know because you were late. You see, that's the advantages of being late. I think I was right on time. Right on time. Will, are you with us? Yeah, I'm with you. It's not a surprise thing. It was just to cut down on our homework. It's not a real big part of the show.
所以威尔，你知道的，听众朋友们对我在上一期节目中迟到了60秒这件事有点微词。你迟到了三分钟。哦，抱歉。等等。那边的算术是怎么算的？那是三分钟。那是100多，所以是3乘以180，180，迟到了180秒。所以我今天早到了，我说，我说，你知道早到的问题在于，你会有风险看到神秘嘉宾是谁。然后发生了什么，我们的神秘嘉宾，这位嘉宾不小心碰到了他们的摄像头盖，暴露了，然后我看到嘉宾是谁了，我太激动了。我不知道。不，我知道，因为你迟到了。你看，这就是迟到的好处。我觉得我非常准时。非常准时。威尔，你在听吗？是的，我在听。这不是什么惊喜环节。这只是为了精简我们的家庭作业。这不是节目的很大一部分。
I think I love it and people love it. I think but but the audience is not it's not a surprise to the audience. The audience because they know it's coming. But I don't know who it is. No, I'm happy that we don't have to see your acting pretending that you don't know who it is because you don't want to see Sean's acting. No, nobody does. You know what I mean? I don't I'm glad that we don't have to watch you let go like, oh my God, who was that? That's and that's why I said I know who the guest is. So I don't have to be excited. So do we start or is there other topics to discuss? No, let's hear some of your pre show pattern. You always think I have pre show pattern. Listen, Regis, you come with a couple of stories. You got anything I can come up with something during our break. We just recorded one listener and now I can talk. I can talk about this. Oh, what happened to our break?
我觉得我爱这个环节，大家也都爱。我觉得，但是，但是对观众来说，对观众来说这并不是什么惊喜。因为观众知道它要来了。但我不知道是谁。不，我很高兴我们不用看你的演技，去假装你不知道他是谁，因为你不想看到肖恩的演技。不，没人想看。你知道我的意思吗？我，我很高兴我们不用看你表现得像，哦天哪，那是谁？这就是为什么我说我知道嘉宾是谁。所以我不需要表现得很兴奋。那么我们是开始呢，还是有其他话题要讨论？不，让我们听听你的一些节目预热吧。你总觉得我有节目预热。听着，里吉斯，你带了几个故事来。你有什么我可以……我能在我们休息的时候想出点什么。听众朋友们，我们刚刚录制完一期，现在我可以说话了。我可以谈谈这个。哦，我们的休息时间怎么了？
I booked a little thing. A job? Yeah, no, no, no, whatever. I booked a two little night stay in this place on Long Island for Valentine's Day. No, for much later than that. Well, are you going to do anything for Scotty for Valentine's Day? We give each other high five. I mean, nothing. We don't do anything. Really? We don't do anything on our anniversary either. Do you guys do a stuff on your anniversary? When is your anniversary? We talked about this. Quick. When's your anniversary? Mine? Yeah, 1111. Is it really? Yeah. Oh my God. Does Jenna and Amanda know that? We're doing next to nothing for Valentine's Day. Sometimes we do gifts for anniversary. I just feel like the whole gift thing and it's it's it's it ends up becoming a bit of a burden, right? Because you're with the person all year and well, but you get I get things that I want from her during the year and she anyway, right?
我预定了一小段行程。一个工作？对，不，不，不，随便啦。我在长岛的一个地方订了两晚的房间，为了情人节。不，比那要晚得多。威尔，你要为斯科蒂过情人节吗？我们互相击掌。我是说，什么都没有。我们什么都不做。真的吗？我们的纪念日我们也不做任何事。你们会在纪念日庆祝吗？你们的纪念日是什么时候？我们谈过这个。快说。你们的纪念日是什么时候？我的？对，11月11日。真的是吗？对。哦天哪。詹娜和阿曼达知道这件事吗？我们对情人节几乎什么都不做。有时候我们会在纪念日送礼物。我只是觉得送礼物这件事，它最后变成了一种负担，对吧？因为你整年都和这个人在一起，而且，但你会，我会从她那里得到我一年中想要的，而且她无论如何，对吧？
Exactly. Like you don't need anything to like save up. No, you're not getting shit until there's an occasion is, I think, weird. So also, you're not going to let corporate America dictate when you tell your wife and show her that you love her with their fucking, you know, you know, if I thought like, well, our net, that's what I would be. I'd be it all would be about not not letting the man win. Yeah, you're going to rise up and fight a man. Yeah, screw the man. Good for you. And it has nothing to do with the fact that you're just too fucking lazy to do anything or think about anybody else other than yourself. I mean, if Valentine's Day was about golf, you'd go out of your fucking way. Celebrate. Why would it have to be one day a year? I would love for you to just put on there now just so Amanda sees it. And you don't plan it that on February 14th, just put golf all day that you're going on a golf trip. Yeah, or something overnight. She'll murder you. Just wait for her to actually do have a little bit of golf scheduled for during the day when the girls are in school. And Amanda's busy doing something. Yeah, a man. Yeah, there is 9, 9, 30. Is that the thing that we're going to do? No, I'm going to. No, I'm going to invite you to this thing.
没错。就像你不需要为了什么东西而存钱。不，直到有什么特殊的日子你才会得到任何东西，我觉得这很奇怪。所以，你也不会让美国企业界来支配你什么时候告诉你的妻子并向她展示你爱她，带着他们那该死的，你知道的，你知道的，如果我想的话，好吧，我们的，这就是我会做的事。我会变成那种绝不让资本主义得逞的人。对，你要奋起反抗资本主义。对，去他的资本主义。真为你骄傲。这跟你只是懒得要死，除了你自己之外懒得为任何人做任何事或考虑任何人，一点关系都没有。我的意思是，如果情人节是关于高尔夫的，你就会竭尽全力去庆祝。为什么非要是一年中的某一天呢？我真希望你现在就在那上面安排一下，好让阿曼达看到。而且你不是计划在2月14日，直接把一整天都安排成去打高尔夫球。对，或者来个过夜什么的。她会杀了你的。等着看她到时候会不会真的在白天女孩们上学、阿曼达忙于别的事情的时候，给你安排一点高尔夫时间。对，阿曼达。对，有9点，9点半。那是我们要去做的那个事吗？不，我要去。不，我要邀请你参加这个活动。
9 30 to 2 30. But Amanda's busy with her work she loves and the girls are in school and then it's listen, it's going to be in the morning and at night. Oh, no, walk us through that. That's when the love happens. And by the way, does it start with that use? Does it start with that? It starts in the morning and then hang it down. Why do your eyes get so heavy? Keep it romantic. Eyes wide. There's nothing romantic about eyes wide. That's that shock. That's what I used to do. Do you guys still do it eyes open, Jason? Lots of eye contact. I used to go out to a bar with my eyes wide open with a drink in my hand like just looking for anybody. That was mostly amphetamines, right? That kept the eyes real bright. Yeah. And then my how you're doing would be much later. After you normally, it's okay to say how you're doing after the deed, right? Yeah, that's right. I'm Sean. Nice to meet you.
9点半到2点半。但阿曼达正忙着她热爱的工作，女孩们在上学，然后，听着，这会在早上和晚上进行。哦，不，给我们讲讲这个过程。那是爱发生的时候。顺便问一下，它是从那个字开始的吗？它是从那个开始的吗？它从早晨开始，然后挂断。为什么你的眼神变得那么深沉？保持浪漫。睁大眼睛。睁大眼睛可一点也不浪漫。那是震惊。那是以前的我。你们现在还那样吗？睁大眼睛，杰森？有很多眼神交流。我以前会睁大眼睛、手里拿着一杯饮料去酒吧，就像在寻找任何人一样。那主要是安非他命吧？那能让眼睛变得特别有神。对。然后我的“你最近怎么样”就会晚得多。通常情况下，在完事之后说“你最近怎么样”是可以的，对吧？是的，没错。我是肖恩。很高兴认识你。
After you can, as you're zipping, you can say, Hey, do you mind small bills and how you do them, by the way? Small bills. Will, what would you do during the break guy for the last half hour? I went upstairs. I was playing with the little kids. We were just goofing around. What does that entail? What do you get down on the floor? You make fun of faces. What do you do with the kids? Legos? I mean, we did do a little bit of Lego. Really? And then, yeah, we did a little bit of Lego and then just with, you know, Denny and... What's his name? Quick. The other one.
事后你可以，当你在拉拉链的时候，你可以说，嘿，你介意零钱吗，以及你最近怎么样，顺便说一句？零钱。威尔，在过去半小时的休息时间里，那个家伙你在干什么？我上楼了。我和小孩子们一起玩。我们就在那儿瞎胡闹。那包括什么？你趴在地板上吗？你做鬼脸吗？你和孩子们玩什么？乐高？我的意思是，我们确实玩了一小会儿乐高。真的吗？然后，是的，我们玩了一会儿乐高，然后就是，你知道，丹尼和……他叫什么名字？快说。另一个。
Well, I was playing with Nash too. Denny and Nash were both there, but I was kind of grabbing Archie or Abel. Those are the other two kids. I know all the kids. I spend more time with my kids. What's your brother's name? Real quick, Will. What's your brother's name? Garrison. Nope. My brother, Chuck, my sweet brother, Chuck, whom I adore. Both sisters. Quick. Tannis and Shanley. All right. So my sisters and I grew up and Chuck was much younger. He is much younger. He's almost 10 years my junior. So my sisters and I grew up. We were closer in age. My older sisters, that two older sisters, Tann and Shan.
好吧，我也在和纳什玩。丹尼和纳什都在那儿，但我当时在抓阿奇或阿贝尔。那是另外两个孩子。我知道所有的孩子。我和我的孩子们在一起的时间更多。你弟弟叫什么名字？快说，威尔。你弟弟叫什么名字？加里森。不对。我弟弟，查克，我亲爱的弟弟查克，我非常崇拜他。两个姐姐。快说。塔尼斯和香利。好吧。所以我和姐姐们一起长大，而查克小得多。他小得多。他比我小将近十岁。所以我和姐姐们一起长大。我们的年龄更接近。我的大姐姐们，两个大姐姐，坦和香。
What's up? They're great with Eddie in Toronto. All of whom you guys know. Sure, yeah. And then Chuck came along and he was a surprise as my parents call him. Oops, baby. Yeah. He was a real pleasant surprise. Sure. And we weren't allowed to call him Chuck or Charlie. So we had to call him Charles. Just oops.
怎么了？他们在多伦多的埃迪那儿过得很好。这些都是你们大家都认识的人。当然，是的。然后查克出生了，正如我父母所说，他是一个意外。哎呀宝宝。是的。他真是一个令人愉快的惊喜。当然。而且我们不被允许叫他查克或查理。所以我们必须叫他查尔斯。只是个意外。
True story. Who said that though? My mom. And so then it became Charles-y, which is even worse. But he still honored her decision about what the name was. Well, yeah. You have to. You've got to honor my mom. Because if you go against Alex, she will fucking take you down. Still to this day? So it's Charles.
真实的树。不过是谁说的？我妈妈。然后这就成了查尔西，这甚至更糟。但他还是尊重了她关于名字是什么的决定。好吧，是的。你必须这么做。你得尊重我妈妈。因为如果你敢违抗亚历克斯，她会他妈的把你搞垮。直到今天依然如此？所以他是查尔斯。
She corrects, she'll correct your, your, your, your grammar or your spell, whatever. I love that. Strangers. She'll, she'll wake you up in the middle of the night to tell you how you're sleeping. Are you sleeping wrong? Yeah. Well, actually the doctors say that on your right side, because it's further away from your heart, like, Hey man, I was asleep for fuck's sake.
她会纠正，她会纠正你的，你的，你的，你的语法或你的拼写，随便什么。我太喜欢这样了。陌生人。她会，她会把你从睡梦中叫醒，告诉你你是怎么睡觉的。你睡姿不对吗？是的。好吧，实际上医生说在你的右侧，因为距离你的心脏更远，就像，嘿，老兄，看在上帝的份上，我刚才睡着了。
Well, actually, technically you weren't asleep. Does Chuck prefer Chuck versus Charles? I think that he doesn't really care as it turns out. And so we still call him Chuck. And but he has a lot of friends who call him Charles and How about Chaz? Ever Chaz? Never any Chaz.
好吧，其实严格来说你并没有睡着。查克更喜欢查克还是查尔斯？我想他其实并不在乎，结果就是这样。所以我们还是叫他查克。而且他有很多朋友叫他查尔斯。那查兹呢？从来没有查兹？从来没有查兹。
You know who really doesn't care? You know who really doesn't care? The guest. Oh. You know what, Sean? I'm sorry, dude. Are you fucking late, dude? First of all, it's my guest and I'll tell you if my guest cares.
你知道谁真的不在乎吗？你知道谁真的不在乎吗？嘉宾。哦。你知道吗，肖恩？对不起，老兄。你他妈迟到了吗，老兄？首先，这是我的嘉宾，我会告诉你我的嘉宾是否在乎。
Good. And I know that she does care because she's interested in people. Oh, it's a female. Yeah. I'm starting to feel like I don't know. You know. I know. Stop.
很好。而且我知道她在乎，因为她对人感兴趣。哦，是个女的。是的。我开始觉得我不知道。你知道。我知道。住手。
Eyebrows high. That you start with eyebrows high. It's a female? What? Yeah. But you know what? Jason likes, Jason does have something come with this, this person in that they were both actors from a young age.
高高的眉毛。你一开始就挑高了眉毛。是个女的？什么？对。但你知道吗？杰森喜欢，杰森确实和这个人有共同点，那就是他们俩都是从小就开始当演员。
Oh. They've both been doing it for a long time. Is this Drew Barrymore? And then they know. I mean, he's had, Drew would be a great guest. Fuck it. I didn't think about it. I'm working on it.
哦。他们俩都干了很长时间了。这是德鲁·巴里摩尔吗？然后他们就知道了。我是说，他有过，德鲁会是个很棒的嘉宾。去他的。我没想到这一点。我在努力。
I know. I wish that. I hope this guest doesn't. I hope my guest doesn't hear that. She'll love it. She has been in so many things. She's one, again, in one of those people, if you start telling all the things she's in, you're going to know who she is.
我知道。我希望。我希望这位嘉宾没听到这个。她会喜欢的。她演过太多作品了。她也是那种人，再次强调，如果你开始数她演过的所有作品，你就会知道她是谁了。
To me, she is one of the funniest people I know. Full stop. Full stop. Every time I spent a moment with this person, even a text from this person, even if I get a certain amount of a text from this person, I get a laugh. Even if I think about this person and the abstract, if I think about two, six people's removed from this person, I'm laughing. Okay.
对我来说，她是我认识的最搞笑的人之一。句号。句号。每次我和这个人呆上一会儿，甚至收到这个人的短信，哪怕我收到这个人的一定长度的短信，我都会笑出来。即使我在抽象地想这个人，如果我想象我和这个人之间隔着两到六个人，我都在笑。好吧。
I had the good fortune of making, I guess what you'd call technically a film together many years ago, but we spent a lot of time overseas. We were in Wales together and we had a lot of laughs. And if it wasn't for each other, we probably both would have gotten completely mad. And she's done so many amazing things, starting with, you know, acclaimed roles like Slums and Beverly Hills, to Oranges the New Black, to Russians all. It is. This is Natasha.
我有幸在多年前制作了一部，我想你可以技术上称之为电影的作品，但我们在海外度过了很长一段时间。我们在威尔士呆在一起，我们有很多欢笑。如果不是为了彼此，我们可能两个人都彻底疯了。她做过那么多惊人的事情，从你知道的备受赞誉的角色开始，比如《比弗利山庄小宝贝》，到《女子监狱》，再到《俄罗斯娃娃》。就是这样。这就是娜塔莎。
The one and only. There you go. Now you do it. Look at her go. There she is. Oh, she's holding a microphone. She's got a hand mic too. She's got a microphone.
独一无二的她。好了。现在轮到你了。看她那干劲。她在那儿。哦，她拿着麦克风。她手里还有一个手持麦克风呢。她有个麦克风。
He asked me to put it somewhere, but I said, I'm not a professional on this. No one's ever done the hand mic. This is, yeah, this is awesome. Now, hey, Will, did she spend any time in the role? It's Drew Barrymore. You're no Drew Barrymore, but you know what you'll do. I love Drew Barrymore. Will, did she spend any time in the Rolls-Royce in Wales?
他让我把麦克风放在某个地方，但我说，我可不是这方面的专业人士。从来没有人用过手持麦克风。这，是的，这太棒了。现在，嘿，威尔，她在里面呆过一段时间吗？是德鲁·巴里摩尔。你可不是德鲁·巴里摩尔，但你知道你要做什么。我爱德鲁·巴里摩尔。威尔，她在威尔士的劳斯莱斯里呆过一段时间吗？
It was in Bentley. No, she never got in the Bentley. We did the Bentley in London. In London, yeah. That's right. Oh, we did do the Bentley in London. Did you ride him back, Natasha? He was your driver?
那是宾利。不，她没上过宾利。我们在伦敦坐过宾利。在伦敦，是的。没错。哦，我们确实在伦敦坐过宾利。你坐在后面吗，娜塔莎？他是你的司机？
Yeah, he was my chauffeur for the entire. I was your chauffeur. It's true. We call that a movie, can you? No, it was a toaster. What was it? What was it called? You guys haven't seen it.
是的，他全程都是我的司机。我当时是你的司机。千真万确。我们把那叫作一部电影，行吗？不，那是个烤面包机。那是什么？那叫什么来着？你们没看过。
It's called Show Dogs. Oh, you guys haven't seen Show Dogs? Oh, no. This sounds hand-drawn. You know what, though? Very nice people involved. Very nice people. Very nice people.
它叫《疯狂原始人》。哦，你们没看过《疯狂原始人》？哦，不。这听起来像是手绘的。不过你知道吗？里面有很多非常好的人。非常好的人。非常好的人。
And a lot of smelly dogs. A lot of dogs. It was live action. Live action. Oh, yeah. Okay. Was it? Do people call you Tasha, Natasha, Tushy?
还有很多臭烘烘的狗。很多狗。那是真人出演。真人出演。哦，是的。好吧。人们叫你塔莎、娜塔莎、塔希吗？
Sure. Sure. Tushy. Tushy. Tushy. Tushy. Hey, Tush. Wait.
当然。当然。塔希。塔希。塔希。塔希。嘿，塔什。等等。
Natasha, Leon, honest to God, one of the people who makes... I said it in the thing. And I'll say it again. God damn it. I've had some of my biggest goddamn laughs have been in your presence and the stuff that you says to me. You say to me. First of all, being with her over there and having this catering truck,
娜塔莎·雷昂，说实话，你是那种能让人……我在节目里说过。我还要再说一遍。该死的。我在你的面前笑得最大声过，还有你对我说的话。你对我说的话。首先，和她一起待在那边，还有这个餐饮卡车，
nice guys, super nice guys. But they would make these sandwiches that were like... It's that white. We were hot for flat whites. They were so hot. Do you want a flat... Would you like a flat white? I'm like, I don't give a shit.
好人，超级好人。但他们会做那种三明治，就像……就是那种白面包。我们当时特别渴望喝澳白咖啡。它们太热了。你想来一杯澳白……你想来一杯澳白吗？我说，我他妈才不在乎呢。
I just want a coffee. What's a flat white? It's a coffee, right? And then... But what was the press sandwich they call it? What would they call it? Do you remember? God, I was just trying to think of that.
我只想喝杯咖啡。什么是澳白？就是咖啡，对吧？然后……但他们管那种压制三明治叫什么？他们管它叫什么？你还记得吗？天哪，我刚想说这个。
A toastie. A toastie. A flat white and a toastie. Oh, a toastie for Tushy. A toastie for Tushy. Have you seen this movie? A toastie is a place. A Neil Simon play.
吐司三明治。吐司三明治和澳白。哦，给塔希的吐司三明治。给塔希的吐司三明治。你看过这部电影吗？吐司三明治是个地方。尼尔·西蒙的戏剧。
A toastie for Tushy. Were you looking to put on weight for the part, Will? No, but I did. No, but I did. Flat white sounds like full fat milk and lots of it. No, it's a grilled cheese sandwich. Well, that's the toastie part. That's the toastie.
给塔希的吐司三明治。你当时是为了这个角色增肥吗，威尔？没有，但我确实胖了。不，但我确实胖了。澳白听起来像是全脂牛奶，而且量很大。不，那是烤奶酪三明治。好吧，那是吐司部分。那是吐司。
That's the toastie. And we were like, at a certain point, and Tushy's like, stop making a big deal. This is a... Why are you guys offering to me like this is some kind of found... Delicacy. Nice people. It's a coffee with milk and a grilled cheese.
那是吐司。然后我们当时，在某个时候，塔希就像是，别大惊小怪了。这是一个……为什么你们把它当成某种新发现的……美味佳肴献给我？好人。这就是加牛奶的咖啡和烤奶酪。
It's been run over by a hot car. You want to have like nine of them a day, though. Yeah, you do want to have nine of them a day. I would. So anyway, so we were there. We had a lot of laughs. God, we had a lot of laughs, huh? Yeah, but it was dark.
它就像是被一辆热车碾过一样。不过你还是会想一天吃九个。是的，你确实会想一天吃九个。我会的。所以无论如何，我们在那儿。我们笑了很多。天哪，我们笑得太开心了，对吧？是的，但那很黑暗。
It was dark, but we had a lot of laughs. Here we are in 2023. It was dark. Have you guys worked together or hung out since then? No. Why? Why are you guys fighting? What happened?
那很黑暗，但我们笑得很开心。我们现在来到了2023年。那很黑暗。从那以后你们合作过或者一起出去玩过吗？没有。为什么？你们为什么在吵架？发生什么事了？
We text. We text. We text every once in a while. We text and... Do you find Will a good texter, Natasha? Great question. I do. I think Will's a pretty solid citizen.
我们发短信。我们发短信。我们偶尔发短信……你觉得威尔是个发短信的好手吗，娜塔莎？好问题。我觉得是的。我觉得威尔是个相当靠谱的公民。
Thank you. As far as guys go, because guys aren't great texters, right? I mean, like, do we get away with not being super responsive? He is not bad. You know, the funny person, but also a deep human being, it turns out. Oh, so he'll send you a long one. Is that what you're saying? Text?
谢谢。就男人而言，因为男人不太擅长发短信，对吧？我是说，比如说，我们是不是可以不用那么快回复也能蒙混过关？他还不赖。你知道，这个搞笑的人，同时也是一个深沉的人，结果证明。哦，所以他会给你发一条很长的短信？你是这个意思吗？发短信？
It's implied. It's implied. We have a language. We have a language between us. And you know what it is? It's between the texts, you know? It's the subtext. It's the subtext.
这是不言而喻的。这是不言而喻的。我们有我们自己的语言。我们之间有一种语言。你知道那是什么吗？是在短信之间，你知道的？那是潜台词。那是潜台词。
Does he have good emoji work? Because that's important. Honestly, I don't remember. I think what's fun, though, is I think you programmed yourself as little big willy or something. Let me look. So I can never find you. It occurs to me periodically to text you and I look up your name and I can't find it. You let him input his number into your phone?
他会用很多好玩的表情符号吗？因为这很重要。老实说，我不记得了。不过我觉得有趣的是，我觉得你把你自己编程成了“小大威利”或者别的什么。让我看看。所以我总是找不到你。我时不时会想要给你发短信，然后我查你的名字却找不到。你让他把他的号码输入到你的手机里了？
Yeah. Yeah, I love that move. That's when you don't know the person's name. Hey, put your phone in my... Put your number in my phone. Do you handle the phone? I'll text you now so that it comes in. And then you know what?
对。对，我喜欢那个举动。那是当你不知道对方名字的时候。嘿，把你的手机放进我……把你的号码放进我手机里。你来操作手机？我现在就发短信给你，这样它就会弹出来了。然后你知道吗？
We'd already been shooting for a month. I was like, this guy's great. We're going to work together. He's so funny. We both have flat whites and toasties. Put your number in here, honey, I said. This is... Wait, Natasha.
我们已经拍了一个月了。当时我想，这家伙太棒了。我们要一起合作。他太搞笑了。我们都喝了澳白和吐司三明治。亲爱的，把你的号码输进来，我说。这简直是……等等，娜塔莎。
All right, I'm texting you right now so that it comes up. So, Natasha, you have like one of the coolest voices to ever walk the earth. I'm assuming you're from New York or a part of New York. Yeah. Born here in the city. And I'm worried about the voice. So, I'm concerned that it's a hot topic. Increasingly, I'm...
好吧，我现在就发短信给你，这样它就会弹出来了。所以，娜塔莎，你的声音是地球上有史以来最酷的声音之一。我猜你是纽约人，或者是纽约某个地方的人。是的。就在这个城市出生。我有点担心这个声音。所以，我担心这是一个热门话题。越来越……
Oh, really? I mean, that doesn't end well, right? That is... No, I think it's identifiable. It's like one of the greatest things in the world. Do you do like voices for cartoons and animated films and stuff like that? You have done? I do a measure, but Will's making much more.
哦，真的吗？我是说，那可没什么好结果，对吧？那是……不，我觉得它很有辨识度。这简直是世界上最棒的事情之一。你会为卡通片和动画电影之类的情形配音吗？你做过吗？我做过一些，但威尔赚得更多。
Yeah, he's killing it. But we've got the new show now, Poker Face. Yeah. I'm excited for when we're all like 70. And we're like, remember the... I think we're there. I think we're there. We're vaguely trying to name projects from the past.
对，他赚大发了。但我们现在有了新剧，《扑克脸》。是的。我很期待我们都七十岁的时候。然后我们会说，还记得那个……我想我们已经到了。我想我们已经到了。我们含糊其辞地试图说出过去项目的名字。
We've maybe or maybe not done. Yes, there's a new program. Poker Face, please. You tell us. A new program. No, you tell us about the program that the folks at home can be watching on the television sets. Natasha, go ahead. You got it.
我们可能做过，也可能没做过。是的，有个新节目。《扑克脸》，求你了。你来告诉我们。一个新节目。不，你来告诉我们国内的观众们可以在电视上看到什么节目。娜塔莎，请吧。你来。
You got it tuned in. You got it tuned in. It's called Poker Face. It's streaming on the cock, right? Cock stream. That's what they call it, the cock. Is it on the cock? We gave it the name...
你调到那个频道了。你调到那个频道了。它叫《扑克脸》。它正在那个什么平台（Cock）上播出，对吧？Cock流媒体。他们就是这么叫它的，那个Cock。它是在Cock上播出的吗？我们给它起名叫……
No, who was it if our guest gave it the name? P-cock. But said it's got to be... You got to call it the cock, obviously. They told me I'm in the flock now. You're in the flock. You're in the cock flock. I'm in the cock flock.
不，如果我们的嘉宾给它起了这个名字，那是谁？P-cock。但它必须是……你当然得叫它Cock。他们告诉我我现在是那个大雕（flock）的一员了。你在这个大雕（flock）里。你在Cock大雕里。我在Cock大雕里。
You're in the cock flock. You're streaming. You're streaming. You got to the cock flock. I'm streaming out the cock flock. If you want to stream in the cock flock, you got it down. P-cock. P-cock flock stream.
你在Cock大雕里。你在流媒体播出。你在流媒体播出。你进了Cock大雕。我在Cock大雕里流媒体播出。如果你想在Cock大雕里流媒体播出，你就得搞定它。P-cock。P-cock大雕流媒体。
Laptop show. And it's... Rian Johnson created it. Rian Johnson. It passed a friend of the show. Yes. Very talented man. Yeah.
笔记本电脑秀。而且它是……莱恩·约翰逊创作的。莱恩·约翰逊。节目老朋友的过客。是的。非常才华横溢的人。是的。
What a nice person. It's called Poker Face. Yeah. It just came out today. Maybe in the middle of the night, I guess they drop shows. It doesn't... To me, that seems weird. Let's start dropping shows at midnight.
真是个好人。它叫《扑克脸》。是的。今天刚上映。也许是在半夜，我猜他们是在半夜上线节目的。这不……对我来说，这似乎有点奇怪。让我们开始在午夜上线节目吧。
You know what I heard it is... Yeah, go ahead. Your name is Will, yes. Yep. I'm currently going by Will, yeah. So, Will. They... Apparently, they do it because if there's a problem, a technical problem, they can fix
你知道我听说这是为什么吗……是的，请说。你叫威尔，对吧？是的。我目前的名字叫威尔，是的。所以，威尔。他们……显然他们这么做是因为如果有问题，技术问题，他们可以在半夜修复
it in the middle of the night. Isn't that something? Doesn't that tell you so much about your friends at Netflix and so on? Really? It seems a little unfinished. Yeah. First of all, let me just say this. Fucking...
它。这不是很有意思吗？这难道不能说明很多关于你在网飞（Netflix）和其他平台的朋友的事情吗？真的吗？这看起来有点没完成。是的。首先，让我这么说吧。他妈的……
Cross your T's and dot your fucking eyes before you release a show, okay? Streamers. Right? Okay. This is just word to the streamers. They're not at the age where you suddenly have that revelation that everybody is just another person and they're just doing their best. Like, I remember being a youth and I would think, surely adults have got this handled.
在发布节目之前，把T字写好，把I字的点点好，好吗？流媒体平台。对吧？好吧。这只是给流媒体平台的一点忠告。他们还没到那种突然有一种顿悟的年龄，即每个人都只是另一个人，他们只是在尽力而为。就像我记得年轻的时候，我想，大人们肯定把这事搞定了。
Right. And once you sort of turn something over, Jason, you know this... From Ozark or I know from running Russian Doll, you know, it's like you hand it over from the edit and you think, okay, that's it. My part is over. Here are the deliverables. Yeah. It's not speed and then you find out about all these additional details while you're
对。一旦你把某些事情移交给别人，杰森，你知道的——从《黑钱胜地》还是我知道的从运作《俄罗斯娃娃》开始，你知道的，就像你从剪辑中把它交出去，然后你想，好吧，就这样。我的部分结束了。这些是交付成果。是的。这不是速度，然后你在剪辑过程中发现了所有这些额外的细节，你会想，怎么会这样？
in the edit and you're like, how the hell? And that's when you realize that everybody is a human being and another bozo on the bus. Yeah. It's amazing that anything comes out semi-round. Another bozo on the bus is the next... My next go. All right. Just the planet is just a fucking huge bus full of bozos.
这就是你意识到每个人都是凡人，不过是车上的另一个小丑的时候。是的。任何东西能做得半圆不缺，都太神奇了。车上的另一个小丑是下一个……我的下一个台词。好吧。这个星球简直就是一辆满载小丑的巨大巴士。
Yeah, it is. And you're being self-effacing there too, I'm sure, and that none of us... He's an idiot, including us. And it takes the best parts of all of us and none of the bad parts to make something kind of semi-round, right? And with all the people it takes, all the people that are involved in a film or a show or anything like that, it's amazing that not one of those people screws it up, you know, beyond recognition.
是的，确实如此。而且你在那里也很自谦，我相信，我们当中没有哪一个……他是个白痴，包括我们在内。要汇聚我们所有人身上最好的部分，剔除所有不好的部分，才能做出有点半圆不缺的东西，对吧？考虑到涉及的所有人，参与一部电影或一个节目或诸如此类的所有人，真是一个奇迹，竟然没有其中一个人把它搞砸到面目全非的程度。
It's like it's a miracle when stuff comes out that's halfway decent. Whereas if you're a painter, it just takes one person, one brush, boom, you get what you get. There's tons of people on the team, right? So many people. And there's so many aspects and layers, and it is crazy that, like when you see old photos of Thelma Shoemaker, yeah, the Scorsese editor, and they're kind of sitting there and the pictures are so iconic and she's over there and they're cutting the film and it's like
就像当东西出来时，能达到差强人意的水平，简直就是一个奇迹。然而，如果你是个画家，只需要一个人，一把刷子，轰，你得到的就是你得到的。团队里有成吨的人，对吧？这么多人。有这么多的方面和层次，这太疯狂了，就像当你看到塞尔玛·舒梅克的老照片时，是的，斯科塞斯的剪辑师，他们坐在那里，照片是如此标志性，她就在那边，他们在剪辑电影，就像
we did it. You know what I mean? That's what the movie is now. And making things in this era as a director or something is bananas. Because even things like, I remember screeners of Russian Novel this season went out without subtitles. And I was like, oh, these people must think I'm really a maniac. Like I'm just making a full European art film.
我们做到了。你知道我的意思吗？电影现在就是这样了。在这个时代作为导演或某种角色制作东西简直是太疯狂了。因为甚至像，我记得这季《俄罗斯娃娃》的试看片发出去时连字幕都没有。当时我想，哦，这些人一定觉得我真是个狂热分子。就像我只是在拍一部完全的欧洲艺术电影。
Just things like that will happen. Yeah. Things can go bad at a lot of different stages. And even if things go great and they're well executed, just the taste might be a little bit different than everything you guys have been doing in development and in production. In other words, if the marketing dresses it up in an outfit that is not reflective of what you're going to see when you actually watch the thing. Now you've told people basically to pardon the metaphor, you've gotten them all excited
诸如此类的事情会发生。是的。事情可能在许多不同的阶段变糟。即使事情进展顺利并且执行得很好，口味也可能与你们在开发和制作中所做的一切略有不同。换句话说，如果市场营销把它打扮成一种并不反映你实际观看时的样子的装扮。现在你基本上告诉人们，原谅这个隐喻，你让他们对一顿美味的中餐兴奋不已，
about a great Chinese food dinner, but you then end up serving them the greatest Italian food you've ever made. But they give it a false negative because it doesn't taste anything like Chinese food. That's fucking metaphor. I forgot you already asked for pardon for that. Sorry. Because I was going to attack that metaphor, luckily. It was a little clunky, but I think the message is sent.
但你最后端上的是你做过的最伟大的意大利菜。但他们给了一个虚假的负面评价，因为它尝起来一点也不像中餐。这真是个他妈的隐喻。我忘了你已经为那个请求原谅了。抱歉。因为我正要攻击那个隐喻，幸运的是。它有点笨拙，但我想信息已经传达了。
And thus, so by the cloak of darkness in the middle of the night, like little elves and they put it, they drop these things on. It's amazing that it all comes out decent, yeah. We'll be right back. This is brought to you in part by Viori clothing, a new perspective on performance apparel. This product, Viori, is just incredibly versatile. It can be used for just about any activity that you can think of like, I'm going to go off the top of my head.
因此，借助半夜的黑暗斗篷，就像小精灵一样，他们把这些东西投放到平台上。这一切能以体面的方式呈现，真是太神奇了。我们马上回来。本节目部分由 Viori 服装赞助播出，这为表演服饰带来了全新的视角。这款产品，Viori，简直具有不可思议的多功能性。它可以用于你能想到的几乎任何活动，比如，我随口说几个。
I'm going to say running or training or swimming or yoga or hiking or also great for lounging or weekend errands. Okay. And dancing, obviously brushing, marching, stomping, drifting, and just loitering. Great for loitering. Everything is designed to work out in, but it doesn't look or feel like it. So it's just so freaking comfortable you're going to want to wear it all the time. It is, honestly, it's more comfortable than whatever you're wearing right now.
我要说的是跑步、训练、游泳、瑜伽、远足，或者也非常适合闲逛或周末跑腿。好吧。还有跳舞，显然还有刷牙、行军、跺脚、漂移，以及单纯的闲逛。非常适合闲逛。所有东西都是为锻炼设计的，但它看起来或感觉起来并不像那样。所以它是如此舒适，你会想一直穿着它。说实话，它比你现在身上穿的任何衣服都要舒服。
I can say that. And I have come to love all my Viori stuff so much that I started with the core short short because it's a classic. And then I started to branch out and I got into the jackets and the longer pants and the stretch and they got stretch and they're nice and they're just relaxed and I could wear them. I'd be working out. And then all of a sudden I jump in the car and I go take care of little biz, you know,
我可以这么说。我已经开始非常喜欢我所有的 Viori 服装了，我从经典款的核心短裤开始。然后我开始拓展，我买了夹克、更长的裤子和弹力裤，它们有弹性，而且很舒适，非常休闲，我可以穿着它们。我在锻炼。然后突然之间我跳进车里去处理一些小事务，你知道，
I'm taking care of biz all over Tizzy. That's town. Anyway, the point is, I just love them and they're so unbelievably comfortable and they look really stylish and you don't look like you're going to attract me. Viori is an investment in your happiness. So for our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase, get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartlist. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartlist.
我在四处处理事务。那是城镇。不管怎样，重点是，我就是爱它们，它们是如此令人难以置信的舒适，而且看起来真的很时尚，你不会看起来像要去……Viori 是对你幸福的一项投资。所以对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买八折优惠，在 Viori.com/smartlist 获取地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装。也就是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartlist。
Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. So go to Viori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Smartlist is brought to you by Nerd Wallet. Hey, smartlist listener, you like to listen to us even though you understand that we are not smart. It's in the name, talented, handsome, sure. But smart is not one of our strong suits.
你不仅能获得首次购买八折优惠，还能享受美国境内订单满 75 美元免运费以及免费退货服务。所以快去 Viori.com/smartlist 探索 Viori 服装的多功能性吧。Smartlist 由 Nerd Wallet 赞助播出。嘿，Smartlist 的听众朋友们，你们喜欢听我们节目，即使你们明白我们并不聪明。名字里就写着呢，有才华，英俊，当然。但聪明并不是我们的强项。
That's where our sponsor comes in, Nerd Wallet, where you can compare top financial products side by side and make smart financial decisions. Nerd Wallet has a whole team of nerds who make you, well, they help you make smart decisions on your next credit card, high yield savings account and more. And these aren't people who just say they're smart. They're like actually smart. They've got CFPs, MBAs, years of experience, and they're using their expertise to offer side by side comparisons and objective ratings on top financial products for you.
这就是我们的赞助商派上用场的地方——Nerd Wallet，在那里你可以并排比较顶级金融产品，并做出明智的财务决策。Nerd Wallet 拥有一整支书呆子团队，他们让你，嗯，他们帮你对你的下一张信用卡、高收益储蓄账户等做出明智的决定。这些人可不仅仅是自称聪明。他们是真的很聪明。他们拥有 CFP、MBA、多年的经验，他们正利用自己的专业知识为你提供顶级金融产品的并排比较和客观评级。
Are you spending more on gas or groceries lately? Of course you are. The world is terrible. Turn that negative into a positive and find a cashback card that rewards you for what you spend the most on. Like for Sean, it's tuna sprinkled with good and plenties. Point is they're going to help him find that. So listener, it's time to stop being smartless and time to get smart with the nerds at Nerd
你最近在汽油或杂货上花的钱更多了吗？你当然是。这个世界太糟糕了。把负面转化为正面，找一张能为你花钱最多的地方提供现金返还的卡。就像对肖恩来说，那是撒了糖果碎的金枪鱼。重点是他们会帮他找到那个。所以听众朋友们，是时候停止装作无所不知（Smartless），开始和 Nerd Wallet 的专家们一起变得聪明（Smart）了。
Wallet. Compare and find top cashback credit cards, savings accounts, and more at nerdwallet.com. Nerd Wallet, the smartest decision for all your financial decisions. Smartless has brought you in part by Zip Recruiter. Award season is coming up and some of the best films from the last year, they got to put together a campaign to try to win all these awards and it takes a big team of people to do that, each with their own specific skill to make these films really successful and have a chance at grabbing those coveted awards.
在 nerdwallet.com 比较并寻找顶级现金返还信用卡、储蓄账户等。Nerd Wallet，你所有财务决策的最明智决定。Smartless 部分由 ZipRecruiter 赞助播出。颁奖季即将到来，过去一年中一些最好的电影必须发起一场宣传战，努力赢得所有这些奖项，这需要一个庞大的团队来完成，每个人都有自己特定的技能，才能让这些电影真正成功并有机会夺得那些梦寐以求的奖项。
And so you need to have the best people for those roles on that team. It's like if you're hiring for your business, you want the most talented people on your team to make your business successful, which is why you should use Zip Recruiter to find a job. And right now, you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Why should Zip Recruiter play a starring role in helping you hire? Because Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology zooms in on the leading candidates for your job and puts them in the spotlight.
所以你需要为团队中的这些角色找到最好的人选。就像如果你在为你的企业招聘，你希望团队中最具才华的人让你的企业成功，这就是为什么你应该使用 ZipRecruiter 来找工作。现在，你可以在 ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist 免费试用。为什么 ZipRecruiter 应该在帮助你招聘中扮演明星角色？因为 ZipRecruiter 强大的匹配技术能够精准锁定你职位的顶尖候选人，并将他们置于聚光灯下。
Zip Recruiter also lets you roll out the red carpet for your candidates you're really interested in by sending them a personal invite to apply to your job. Additionally, Zip Recruiter offers showstopping labels that speak to job flexibility like urgent, or training provided, or remote, and more. If there was an award for easiest hiring, it would go to... Unvelope, please. Zip Recruiter. Four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the
ZipRecruiter 还允许你为你真正感兴趣的候选人铺设红地毯，向他们发送申请你职位的个人邀请。此外，ZipRecruiter 还提供引人注目的标签，说明工作的灵活性，比如紧急、提供培训、远程等等。如果有一个关于最简单招聘的奖项，它将颁给……请揭晓信封。ZipRecruiter。十分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。
first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free, ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. And that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. You've had...
亲自去看看吧。访问这个专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter：ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。那是 ZipRecruiter.com 斜杠 S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在，让我们回到节目中。你经历过……
You've been in... Listen, let's be honest. You've been in show business since day one. Out the womb. Out the womb. You've been in show business. You've been doing this thing. You've been out there.
你一直在……听着，说实话。你从第一天起就一直在娱乐圈。从娘胎里出来就开始。从娘胎里出来。你就在娱乐圈了。你一直在做这件事。你一直在外面闯荡。
You've been doing it. And you've done it all. You've been a star. You've been a thing. And now you're a filmmaker. Excuse me very much. Storyteller, well, storyteller. Storyteller.
你一直在做这件事。而且你什么都做过了。你当过明星。你是个大人物。现在你是个电影制作人。非常不好意思。讲故事的人，好吧，讲故事的人。讲故事的人。
I don't know if you know about our version to the term storyteller, because now everybody's a storyteller. Everybody just wants to tell stories, you know? I'm featuring Gideon from all that jazz, coming out the womb with jazz hands, you know? Disgusting. It's a disgusting image. Honestly. Only Sean likes it.
我不知道你们是否知道我们对“讲故事的人”这个词的厌恶，因为现在每个人都是讲故事的人。每个人都只想讲故事，你知道吗？我脑海里浮现出《爵士春秋》里的吉迪恩，一出生就带着爵士手势，你知道吗？真恶心。这是一个恶心的画面。老实说。只有肖恩喜欢。
Showtime. You can go park and you can get a fabulous teamster driving you over from parking to base camp. And they're like, well, you know, as a storyteller, I'm like, you're telling a story too? Everybody's telling a story here today, huh? Everybody's got a story. Everybody's got a story. But you started...
演出开始。你可以去停车，然后会有一支极棒的团队司机用车把你从停车场送到大本营。他们会说，好吧，你知道，作为一个讲故事的人，而我会想，你也在讲故事吗？今天这里每个人都在讲故事，是吧？每个人都有一个故事。每个人都有一个故事。但你开始……
You've done so many different things and so many different eras of your life. Forget eras of the world, eras of your life. You must look back and every... Is every part of your life... And Jason, you too, is marked by what you were working on, what you were doing professionally. When it's so ever-present, you know, guys like Sean and I grew up and we didn't grow up making movies and we didn't start doing that and acting and getting paid for it until we were in our 20s and 30s, you guys were doing when you were kids, it must be this
你做过那么多不同的事情，经历过你人生的那么多不同时代。忘掉世界的时代吧，是你人生的时代。你一定回首过往，而且每个……你人生的每一部分——杰森，你也是——都是由你在做什么工作、你在从事什么职业来标记的。当它是如此无处不在的时候，你知道的，像肖恩和我这样的家伙，我们长大时并没有拍电影，我们也没有开始做那个，没有在演员行业拿到报酬直到我们二十多岁和三十多岁的时候，你们在还是孩子的时候就在做了，这一定是一个……
thing that is constantly like it's been ever-present in your life. What is that experience like, Natasha? I know Jason's answer. I mean, I will say that there was a time I experienced it almost like... Are you familiar with this Fellini short film, Spirits of the Dead? So it's part of a trilogy called Spirits of the Dead. They are not familiar. Which is...
不断地，就像它一直存在于你的生活中的那种经历。那种体验是什么样的，娜塔莎？我知道杰森的答案。我的意思是，我要说的是，曾几何时，我经历它的感觉几乎就像是……你熟悉费里尼的短片《死者的精神》吗？所以它是名为《死者的精神》的三部曲的一部分。他们不熟悉。也就是……
But you are. Which is... Anyway, they're adaptations of Edgar Allen Poe short stories and one is Roger Vadim and one is Louis Malin and then there's the Fellini one is called Toby Dammit with a turnstamp and it's very... It's very dark. It's almost like Satanic and it's like a warped circus and it's sort of that version of the showbiz experience that's very wrapped in darkness and it's drunk and it's high
但你熟悉。也就是……不管怎样，它们是对埃德加·爱伦·坡短篇小说的改编，其中一个是罗杰·瓦迪姆的，一个是路易·马勒的，然后还有一个费里尼的，叫做《托比·达米特》，带有……这非常……非常黑暗。它几乎就像是撒旦式的，就像一个扭曲的马戏团，某种程度上那是演艺界经历的那个版本，充满了黑暗，喝醉了，嗑药了，
and it's kind of that. And so I definitely would say that I'd had that window and then now all of a sudden, in my 40s, it somehow really flipped over the past kind of decade where there's a sort of a beauty to all of that memory and attachment because now all of a sudden the players are becoming so recycled of friends of like 25 years or something, you know, whether that's a Maya or your Amy and a rationale or like something that leads me to... With Ryan, that was so much of why I was so game for this show is I could tell sort of spot him from a distance of, oh, you're going to be one of these players.
差不多就是那样。所以我绝对会说我曾有过那样一段经历，然后突然之间，在我四十多岁的时候，在过去的十年左右，它不知怎么地真的彻底翻转了，那些记忆和情感中有一种美感，因为现在突然之间，那些演员变得如此循环往复，都是25年左右的朋友之类的，你知道的，不管是玛雅还是你的艾米和纳什，或者类似的事情，这让我……对于瑞安，这也是我为什么这么乐意接拍这个节目的很大一部分原因，我可以从远处认出他，哦，你将成为这些演员之一。
Like as soon as we work together, well, I was like, oh, of course we're going to end up working together again. He's going to be so funny when he's old. Like I don't even really think of it as show dogs, this movie we made that I guess involved talking dogs. I think of it as you and I walking around Wales being like, what's happening? What are we doing? We're having more flat whites, like doubled over laughing hysterically and that whenever
就像我们合作过之后，威尔，我就想，哦，我们当然最终还会再次合作。他老了以后会这么搞笑。我甚至不认为这是《疯狂原始人》，这部我们拍过的、我猜涉及会说话的狗的电影。我把它看作是你和我走在威尔士，想着，发生什么了？我们在做什么？我们正在喝更多澳白，笑得前仰后合，而且每当
I see you, I think of us laughing. I don't really think of us in a essentially failed talking dog picture, you know what I mean? Yeah. So somewhere along the way, it went from like a head trip about the thing to the beauty of the thing of like a life in the arts. It all comes back. It beautifully said.
我看着你，就会想起我们一起大笑的样子。我其实并没有把我们想象成那种本质上很失败的“会说话的狗”的电影里的那种人，你知道我的意思吗？是的。所以在某个过程中，它从一件关于某件事的头脑风暴，变成了那件事的美好，就像是一种艺术人生。一切都会重现。说得太好了。
Yeah. I love that. Jay, what's your experience like? I, I, I joked earlier on that I know your answer. I don't know your answer. I mean, you're similarly, you've, it's been such a ever present thing in your life. Yeah. I mean, and there's good and bad of that.
是的。我太喜欢了。杰伊，你的经历是怎样的？我，我，我刚才开玩笑说我知道你的答案。其实我并不知道你的答案。我的意思是，你也有类似的经历，这对你来说是一件一直都存在于生活中的事。是的。我的意思是，这其中有好也有坏。
I'm sure Natasha, you'd agree. It's like there's, there's, there's something great about having started so young, but then there's also like, well, maybe we should have tried to do something else too or, you know, something, well, it's not my interview, but I feel very, very lucky as I'm sure you do Natasha that we're both still working in this business, you know, longevity is a, is a real, um, uh, metal. I, I, I, I, or rather I should say I'm very, I'm proud of that, that I'm still making a living at it.
娜塔莎，我相信你也会同意的。这就好比，这么早就出道固然有很多棒的地方，但同时也会想，嗯，也许我们当时也应该尝试做点别的，或者，你知道的，某种，嗯，虽然这不是我的采访，但我感到非常非常幸运，我相信你也是，娜塔莎，我们俩现在都还在这一行里工作，你知道的，长青不倒真的是一种，嗯，一种勋章。我，我，我，或者更准确地说，我应该说我很为此骄傲，我靠这个还在谋生。
Cause it's fickle. And is that how you came to being like, oh shit, now I got to, I got to start writing and directing. For me, I, I look back and I realize that, so I think at five years old, um, I'm on Peewee's Playhouse or whatever. And I know he's not very trendy right now, but at the time, you know, when I was 15 and I was in the, this Woody Allen movie, it was like such a big deal and it felt like, ah, this is the cherry on top of a decade of acting, something my parents put me into.
因为这一行太变化无常了。这就是让你开始觉得，哦操，现在我得，我得开始写作和导演的原因吗？对我来说，我回过头来意识到，所以我想在我五岁的时候，嗯，我上了《皮威的游乐园》或者别的什么节目。我知道他现在不是很时髦，但当时，你知道的，当我15岁的时候，我参演了伍迪·艾伦的这部电影，这真是一件大事，感觉就像是，啊，这是长达十年的演艺生涯上的樱桃点缀，这是我父母让我走上的道路。
And then at 16, I was skipped by Tish to be a film and philosophy double major. I was like, Oh, well, I'll read all these philosophy books and then I'll write and direct these sort of Bergman, but funny movies cause I'll be a filmmaker now. And then it sort of, you know, took 20 years to kind of get back there and it ended up being, I guess, all the things. Was that similar to your version of how you got here? Yeah, you, you sort of, you have career, like I wanted to be the next Robert De Niro, you know, when I was like 12 and it was like, well, yeah, but, um, I'm getting kicked out
然后到了16岁，我被提许学院录取，主修电影和哲学双学位。当时我想，哦，好吧，我会读完所有这些哲学书，然后我会写并导演这些有点像伯格曼风格但又很有趣的电影，因为我现在要成为一名电影人了。然后它大概，你知道的，花了20年时间才算回到那个起点，最后它变成了，我猜，所有这一切。这和你来到这里的经历类似吗？是的，你，你某种程度上，你经历过职业生涯，就像我12岁的时候想成为下一个罗伯特·德尼罗，你知道的，当时觉得，嗯，对，但是，嗯，我正因为
of class for being a class clown. So maybe, When you got kicked out of class, they were, they just pulled the bus over and let you off at Wilshire and Santa Monica cause he was, he was going to school in a massage bus that toured, toured Los Angeles, kids massaging each other. Not untrue. Um, but yeah, you know, you're like, well, I, you know, maybe I'll, I'll, I'll go for the goal.
在课堂上当班级小丑而被开除。所以也许，当你被赶出课堂时，他们只是把巴士停在威尔希尔和圣莫尼卡交界处让你下车，因为他当时坐的是一辆在洛杉矶巡回的按摩巴士，孩子们在上面互相按摩。这倒不是假的。嗯，但是，你知道的，你会觉得，好吧，我，你知道的，也许我，我，我以后再去追求那个目标。
Uh, later. Meanwhile, I, I need to kind of make a living, um, and, and aren't we both so, so fortunate that we've stayed a float long enough to circle back to our original sort of dreams of doing things that are different than what we've kind of become known for. Right. But the thing is, but, but so interesting about both of you guys is I, I'm not even joking. I'm learning stuff now that you guys probably learned, you know, 20 years before me having started so young, so you guys did have, what's that?
嗯。同时，我，我需要维持生计，嗯，而且，难道我们俩不都是那么那么幸运，能够浮在水面上足够久，从而能够回到我们最初的梦想，去做一些和我们现在所为人熟知的事情不同的事情吗？对的。但问题是，关于你们两个最有趣的事是，我甚至不是在开玩笑。我现在正在学习一些东西，这些东西你们可能在20年前就学会了，因为你们出道太早了，所以你们确实有，什么？
I don't believe that. Sorry. I don't believe that you're learning stuff now. I, I, I, I, I just general, sorry, just a single sense. Yeah. Sorry. I just had to cut you off there. I know you very well.
我不信。对不起。我不相信你现在才在学东西。我，我，我，我，我只是大致说说，抱歉，只是随口一说。是的。抱歉。我不得不打断你。我很了解你。
And it doesn't seem like you're learning anything, but, but, but it would, it's not surprising Sean. And actually I think that you, you're, you're right. I have the same thing. I learned stuff way later, the stuff that just that they know and because they've grown up. It's in your bodies already. And worse, I'm still not, no joke.
而且你看起来也不像是在学什么东西，但是，但是，但是肖恩，这并不令人意外。实际上我觉得你，你，你说得对。我也有同感。我学到东西的时间要晚得多，那些他们懂得的东西，仅仅是因为他们成长了。那些东西已经刻在你们的身体里了。更糟的是，说真的，我还是。
I'm still like learning stuff that's in your bones, but they're both, but they're both smart. You guys, you're both smart. You're both super talented. And so it's no wonder that you've kind of maintained that. And I think people say, well, you know, this guy, he had a bad, he had a, he was young and he was a performer and then he didn't really work out and, you know, truth be told, they might have not been that smarter of that talent than, I mean, let's be honest.
我还是在学那些刻在你们骨子里的东西，但你们俩，但你们俩都很聪明。你们俩，你们俩都很聪明。你们俩都超级有才华。所以难怪你们能一直保持这种状态。我觉得人们会说，哦，你知道的，这家伙，他经历不好，他年轻时是个表演者，然后后来没有真正混出名堂，你知道的，老实说，他们可能并不比，我的意思是，说实话，他们并没有那么聪明或者那么有才华。
You know. You can, you can get away with quite a bit of non-smarts and non-talent when you're, you know, eight, nine, 10, 12, 13 years old, just to sell the gum, cereal. These kids are really dumb. And I want that. That's going to be. I like that's a man. We've transitioned to attacking children.
你知道的。当你八九岁、十岁、十二三岁的时候，你其实可以靠着一点也不聪明和毫无才华蒙混过关，只要去卖口香糖、麦片就行了。这些小屁孩真的太笨了。而我就想要那个。那会是。我喜欢那个，天哪。我们已经开始过渡到攻击儿童了。
The thing about kids is they're fucking stupid and then they come out here and they try to do grown-up stuff with the kids shed and I'm all done with it. They're crapping in their pants. You know. I used to have this. Get a license. You're dumb fuck. I used to have this acting teacher.
关于小孩子，有一点就是他们他妈的太蠢了，然后他们跑到这里来，试图在小孩子的地盘上做成年人的事，我真是受够了。他们在裤子里拉屎。你知道的。我以前有这个。去考个驾照吧。你个大笨蛋。我以前有这个表演老师。
I used to have this acting teacher in New York. This guy, George Aloros. He was a great guy. And he'd go, when you're working with a kid. What fucking experience is a kid going to draw on? They don't fucking know anything. But I'm fascinated by this because you'll see kids in movies and stuff who have this unbelievable range of ability to express emotion.
我以前在纽约有个表演老师。这人叫乔治·阿洛罗斯。他是个好人。他会说，当你和小孩合作时。一个小孩子能有什么他妈的人生经验可以借鉴？他们他妈的什么都不懂。但我对此很着迷，因为你会看到电影里的小孩表现出这种令人难以置信的丰富情感表达能力。
You're like, how do you know that? Isn't that bizarre? They're psychos. Total psychos. They're psychos. Exactly. I remember when I auditioned for a little house in a prairie, I had to cry for Michael Landon and I remember just, you train your brain to think about the most horrific thing
你会想：你怎么会懂这个？这不是很诡异吗？他们都是神经病。绝对的神经病。他们就是神经病。一点没错。我记得我去为《草原小屋》试镜时，我必须得在迈克尔·兰登面前哭出来，我记得当时，你训练自己的大脑去想世界上最恐怖的事情，
in the world to bring up the tears and then use 11 and it's just like, it's a muscle that is very unhealthy, you know, like still to this day, if I got a crying camera, I will think of the most horrific thing I can, which currently is something terrible happening to my children, knock on wood. So I look at pictures on my iPhone right before they start rolling of my sweet children and I imagine horrific things happen to them, I start getting weepy and I say, okay, let's go. It's like, what are we doing?
以此来逼出眼泪，当时我才11岁，这就好比，这是一种很不健康的肌肉记忆，你知道的，直到今天，如果我要在镜头前哭泣，我还是会去想我能想到的最恐怖的事情，目前这通常是我孩子身上发生了可怕的事情，敲木头。所以在开拍前，我会看着我iPhone里我可爱孩子们的照片，然后想象可怕的事情发生在他们身上，我就开始眼泪汪汪，然后我说，好吧，我们开始吧。这就好比，我们在干什么？
Yeah. We need new jobs. We need new jobs. That's horrible. This is a fuck up. I know. Natasha, you don't do anything like that. Do you?
对。我们需要换工作。我们需要换工作。这太可怕了。这真是一团糟。我知道。娜塔莎，你不会做那种事吧？对吗？
I mean, you don't think about Jason's horrible things happening to the kids. Weirdly I do. Which if she needs to laugh. That's great. What a similar process. Yeah. Oh my God. It would be so horrible if something happened to these beautiful children.
我是说，你不会去想杰森那些发生在孩子身上的可怕事情吧。奇怪的是我还真会。如果她需要笑的话。那太棒了。多么相似的过程。是的。天哪。如果这些可爱的孩子身上发生点什么，那可真是太可怕了。
I brought this up before. I think, Jason, you used to, if people are breaking up on, if people are, you know, corpsing, like going up and laughing on set, that you'll think about awful things happening to them. Close. I actually, this is a true story. Will Speckle me that? When you guys were doing the office Christmas party, he said that, and everybody was cracking
我以前提过这个。我想，杰森，你以前，如果人们在片场笑场，就是那种笑场、在片场笑出来的话，你会去想可怕的事情降临在他们身上。接近了。其实，这是一个真实的故事。威尔·斯佩克告诉我这个的？当你们在拍《办公室圣诞派对》时，他这么说了，然后每个人都笑得
up doing this one scene. You go, how are you not cracking them? You said, I just imagine all of them dying. Yeah. It's not, it's actually worse than that. If pinching my leg under camera, under frame doesn't work, I will actually just think they, these other actors that are being very, very funny are ruining the movie. That they're being terrible actors and they're destroying this project.
前俯后仰，正在拍其中一场戏。你说，你怎么能不笑场？你说，我只是想象他们所有人都死了。是的。这其实，比那还要糟糕。如果掐大腿在镜头外、在画幅外不管用的话，我其实就会去想，这些表现得非常非常搞笑的其他演员正在毁掉这部电影。他们是糟糕的演员，正在毁掉这个项目。
I love that. That's worse than something that I'm dying. Exactly. I get into disdain. Nothing worse than ruining it. You guys are killing comedy. Disdain wipes the humor out of my world. So Natasha, where was, all right.
我太喜欢了。这比想着我死还要糟糕。一点没错。我心里充满了鄙视。没有什么比毁掉它更糟糕的了。你们俩在谋杀喜剧。鄙视把幽默从我的世界里抹去了。所以娜塔莎，在哪，好吧。
So now you had all these great things. You've done all these things. As you mentioned, you did, you know, which at a time, again, not very popular for a lot of reasons, but the Woody Allen picture, that was always like the, the kind of the hallmark of somebody who has accomplished a lot when you get asked to be part of one of those ensembles. You go, this is somebody who's important. It was kind of like a stamp, right? To get cast in those, at that moment, you are an important, so you had that, you were
所以现在你有了这些美好的经历。你做过所有这些事情。正如你所提到的，你演过，你知道的，虽然在当时，再次说明，由于很多原因并不太受欢迎，但那部伍迪·艾伦的电影，一直以来就像是一个标志，代表着当你被邀请加入其中一个演员阵容时，你就是一个成就非凡的人。你会觉得，这是一个举足轻重的人。这就像是一个印章，对吧？在那个时刻被选中参演那些电影，你就是一个大人物，所以你有过这些经历，你一直在
doing a lot of very cool stuff and then you've gone on to do lots of, you started working in television. And in fact, you were one of the first streaming shows around was Orange is the New Black and you became, you're a regular on that for seven years. Yeah, it was a long time. Yeah, I just said, so great. As somebody who was such a stalwart in film, what was that transition like for you going to doing a, in effect, a TV series?
做很多非常酷的事情，然后你继续做了很多，你开始涉足电视圈。事实上，你参演了最早的一批流媒体剧集之一《女子监狱》，并且你在其中连续七年成为了常驻演员。是的，那是一段很长的时间。是的，我刚才说，太棒了。作为一名电影界的中流砥柱，你过渡到去拍一部，实际上是电视剧集，那是一种什么样的体验？
Was that something that you were interested in or, or did you need the job at the time and you're like, fuck it, this is a great opportunity or, I don't know. Did you like that process? Yeah, it was super weird. I mean, I definitely, I even hear the way Ryan and I will talk about this, you know, poker face mystery show and we, we share a love of Philip Marlowe, you know, and Altman's the Long Goodbye. And, you know, I love it so much that in co-creating Russian All, there's like a cat oatmeal and
那是你感兴趣的东西，还是说你当时需要这份工作，觉得管他呢，这是一个绝佳的机会，或者，我不知道。你喜欢那个过程吗？是的，这超级奇怪。我的意思是，我绝对，我甚至听到我和瑞恩谈论这个《扑克脸》悬疑剧的方式，你知道的，我们对菲利普·马洛有着共同的热爱，你知道的，还有奥尔特曼的《漫长的告别》。而且，你知道的，我太喜欢了，所以在共同创作《轮回派对》时，里面有一只猫叫燕麦，
it's a direct rip from, from the Long Goodbye. Like there's so much about that Philip Marlowe thing. And, you know, when I think of Peter Falk and like the love of Peter Falk, it's not just Colombo. I really think about all those Cassavetes films that, you know, as a teenager, I was like, this is who I am and then I'll be in them and write them, direct them. And you were, you were an indie film person. Yeah.
这是直接从《漫长的告别》里抄来的。关于菲利普·马洛的元素实在太多了。而且，你知道的，当我想到彼得·福克以及对彼得·福克的喜爱时，不仅仅是因为《神探可伦坡》。我真的想到了所有那些卡萨维蒂的电影，你知道的，作为一个青少年，我当时想，这就是我，然后我要参演这些电影并亲自编剧、导演。而你，你曾经是个独立电影人。是的。
And it was just, you know, and Philip Marlowe, whatever, Jack Nicholson, Chinatown, and he also has references I don't have like the Rockford Files or Magnum PI. Like I sort of, he seems to sort of know all of the lineage and I'm pretty strictly film or if anything, even, you know, John Fonte or Raymond Chandler books, which he knows all of that too, but I'm just saying that I don't have that same fluency with television. So for sure, I always kind of raised myself on movies and thought that was the big goal. And then, yeah, I mean, basically I was a, you know, pretty serious junkie for, I don't know, I guess I lost like a decade in there, which is always why, you know, I'm pickled
这只是，你知道的，还有菲利普·马洛，不管怎样，杰克·尼克尔森的《唐人街》，他也有一些我不知道的梗，比如《洛城法网》或者《夏威夷神探》。我感觉他似乎知道所有的传承，而我相当严格地只看电影，或者如果有的话，甚至是，你知道的，约翰·方特或雷蒙·钱德勒的书，这些他也都知道，但我只是说我对电视没有那种同样的熟稔。所以毫无疑问，我一直是以电影为生并认为那是终极目标。然后，基本上我曾是一个，你知道的，相当严重的瘾君子，持续了，我不知道，我猜我在那期间荒废了大约十年，这也是为什么，你知道的，
so I look terrific, never looked better. And yeah, also I have the youth and the vibrancy of a 30-something thanks to losing a decade of life. You know what I mean? So those are the upshots, Will. You're kind of, you're kind of like a running back, like a football player who, who, who, who goes on the sidelines for 10 years and comes back and he hasn't been getting hurt for 10 years.
我被浸泡腌制过了，所以我看起来棒极了，从来没这么好过。是的，多亏了荒废了十年的生命，我还拥有了30多岁人的青春和活力。你知道我的意思吗？所以这些都是好处，威尔。你有点像，你有点像一个跑卫，就像一个美式足球运动员，他在场边休息了10年然后回来，这10年里他都没有受伤。
So he's still young. Right? So that's you. There was, there was 10 years of fun and frolicking and no, no, no real career work because I had one of those decades. You did? Yeah, yeah. I didn't really know that about you.
所以他依然年轻。对吧？所以那就是你。曾经有，曾经有10年的寻欢作乐，没有，没有真正认真的职业工作，因为我经历过那样的一个十年。你也有？对，对。我其实不知道你这边的经历。
And I didn't about yours either. That's why I'm asking. Oh really? That's what I meant by the Fellini short film, I guess it was too obscure. I guess I was speaking in coded language only myself. I came out of it with, first of all, an appreciation of employment and another, another at bat, another crack at relevancy. And you were, and you were partying pretty hard, let's just say it that way, right?
我也不知道你的。这就是我为什么要问。哦，真的吗？我刚才说的费里尼短片就是这个意思，我猜它太晦涩了。我当时大概是在用只有自己才懂的密码在说话。我从那段经历中走出来，首先，是对工作的感激，还有另一次机会，另一次重获关注的契机。而且你当时也玩得很疯，我们不妨直说，对吧？
You were Jay? Yeah, I mean, I, I don't, I mean, sure, I mean, I was out having fun every night. It was more sort of hedonism and debauchery than, than, than, you know, something I felt like I needed to check myself in for a war. But either way, I came out of it with like that appreciation, but also kind of seasoned and weathered and a little bit broken. And I felt that that really helped some of my acting stuff, some of the directing stuff. And my, my taste in things was, I think, more sophisticated, having gone through something
你当时是这样吗，杰伊？是的，我的意思是，我并不，我是说，当然，我的意思是，我每天晚上都出去玩。与其说那是什么需要我去戒毒所报到的事情，不如说更像是一种享乐主义和纵情声色。但无论如何，我带着那种感激之情从那段经历中走了出来，同时也变得成熟、饱经沧桑并且有点破碎。我觉得这确实对我的表演和导演工作有所帮助。而且我的品味，我认为也变得更加成熟了，毕竟经历了一些
a little less privileged and protected than, you know, being wrapped up in the business. Well, I would say for sure, because it's really all the things you need to know about the human condition, belly of the beast, heart of darkness, it's kind of just seemingly like why Kerouac goes on the road, you know, I think that anyway, that the romanticism that surrounds it, you do sort of, you know, return with, of course, the only problem is if you make it out alive and then they sort of, the thing that's less spoken is, you know, just how, just how dark those dark nights of the soul are, just how much that it ultimately, you know, doesn't work.
没那么特权和受保护的事情，而不仅仅是被包裹在商业运作之中。嗯，我肯定会这么说，因为这真的是了解人类境况所需的一切，兽穴，黑暗之心，这某种程度上看起来就像凯鲁亚克在路上一样，你知道的，我认为无论如何，那种围绕着它的浪漫主义，你确实会，你知道的，带着它回归，当然，唯一的问题是如果你能活着出来，然后接下来，不那么常被人提起的事情是，你知道，那些灵魂的黑暗之夜是多么的黑暗，它最终，你知道，是多么的无用。
Like you can't, you can't sort of stop the negative self-talking, self-criticizing mind, no matter what you do, so you're sort of really doomed to then also sort of take the years to correct it. It's a long way of saying that's how I ended up on, you know, what at the time was an internet show. Yeah. Like as you guys know so much about Netflix and kind of who knew, but certainly that was not the dream.
就像你无法，你无法阻止那个消极自我对话、自我批判的心灵，无论你做什么，所以你注定还是要花上好几年的时间来纠正它。这绕了一个大圈子，其实就是说我是怎么最终参演了，你知道的，当时的一部网络剧。是的。就像你们对网飞非常了解，谁能料到呢，但那绝对不是我的梦想。
But it's all right. Well, Hulu's a, Hulu's a different thing, but, so did you, but Natasha, thank you for laughing. I really appreciate it. Well, I was going to say, I just wanted to say, yeah, you know, you can, you run the risk of course, in those, of doing irreparable damage and not just sort of physically like that you can't come back from, but almost, almost spiritually and, and, and right. You can, if that darkness gets too dark, can you make that rebound and come back and live
不过没关系。好吧，Hulu是，Hulu是另一回事，但是，所以你，但是娜塔莎，谢谢你笑。我真的很感激。嗯，我本来想说，我只是想说，是的，你知道的，你当然会面临风险，在那些经历中，造成不可修复的损害，不仅仅是那种无法恢复的身体上的损害，几乎是，几乎是精神上的，还有，对。你可以，如果那种黑暗变得太深，你还能反弹回来并过上
a life that, where you're not too scarred by the self-inflicted wounds? And are you able to let it go? It's a razor's edge. Are you able to let it go? Are you able to move on? Some of that is like, can you give yourself a break? Can you forgive yourself? Can you forgive all those things?
一种没有被自残的伤口留下太多疤痕的生活吗？你能够放下它吗？这就像走在剃刀边缘。你能够放下它吗？你能够继续前进吗？其中一部分就像是，你能放自己一马吗？你能原谅自己吗？你能原谅所有这些事情吗？
Can you, can you make that, that step? And I look from what I know about you, you know, I think that one of the great things is, is you're a very open person and I know that you help a lot of people and you're very generous. You have, you're very generous of spirit and of heart. And I bet you that's a big part of, of how you've been able to come back. I've seen it firsthand and it's one of the things that I really admire about you. And I appreciate that.
你能，你能迈出那一步吗？从我所了解的你来看，你知道，我认为最棒的一点之一就是，你是一个非常坦诚的人，我知道你帮助了很多人，而且你非常慷慨。你的精神和内心都非常慷慨。我敢打赌，这是你能重新站起来的一个重要部分。我亲眼见证过，这也是我非常钦佩你的地方。我很感激。
But let's give Natasha some questions and some, uh, Thank you, honey. Wait, Sean, are you doing an Oscar Levan situation? He sure is. And what is the date in the theater, please? Good night, Oscar. It's April. It opens April 24th at the Belasco Theater in New York, New York.
但让我们给娜塔莎提几个问题，还有，嗯，谢谢你，亲爱的。等等，肖恩，你在搞奥斯卡·莱万特那一套吗？他当然是在。请问在剧院上演的日期是？晚安，奥斯卡。是在四月。4月24日在纽约贝拉斯科剧院开幕。
You know, I am obsessed with Oscar Levan. Oh, really? I love it, figures of all time and I feel like with that coincidence, we'd be remiss to not say, I mean, that's a guy who knows about this whole game. Oh God, all of it. Yeah. Yeah. He was, one of my favorite one-liners was, uh, he said, I take prescription pills for
你知道的，我对奥斯卡·莱万特痴迷至极。哦，真的吗？我太喜欢了，史上最伟大的人物之一，我觉得有了这个巧合，如果我们不说点什么的话那就太失职了，我的意思是，那可是一个真正懂这个行当的人。哦天哪，全懂。是的。是的。他，我最喜欢的俏皮话之一是，嗯，他说，我吃处方药来对付
the side effects. Right. Sure. Well, Natasha, it sounds like you're coming to opening night with us on the 24th. Yeah. April 24th. I don't want to know. We're going to be in New York.
副作用。没错。当然。嗯，娜塔莎听起来你要和我们一起去24号的开幕之夜了。是的。4月24日。我不想知道。我们要去纽约。
Come on. Come with us. It's going to be amazing. Sean knows. Sean. Yeah. We're here. He said, don't let him know if you're there.
来吧。跟我们一起去。那一定会太棒了。肖恩知道。肖恩。对。我们在这。他说，别让他知道你在那儿。
Hey. I think he means before the curtain. So once the curtain goes up. Sean, that was so funny. That last line was so funny. God, that would be my worst nightmare. I'm going to get Natasha to come with us. So, uh, but Natasha, do you, by the way, we can cut this or whatever, but I'm always
嘿。我想他的意思是幕布拉开之前。所以一旦大幕拉开。肖恩，太好笑了。最后那句话太好笑了。天哪，那将是我最可怕的噩梦。我要把娜塔莎一起拉去。所以，嗯，但是娜塔莎，你，顺便说一句，我们可以把这段剪掉或者随便怎样，但我一直
fascinated by addiction. It's been in my family. It's been in my friends, whatever it's been all around me my whole life. Because do you ever feel a pull back there? And what do you do to stop that desire if you do feel that? Or are you so on the other side that you're like, not at all? You know, it's helpful to get older because you're, you're lazier. You know what I mean?
对成瘾这事很着迷。它曾存在于我的家庭中，存在于我的朋友中，不管怎样，它伴随了我的一生。因为你有没有过那种被它重新拉回去的感觉？如果你确实感到了那种渴望，你是怎么阻止它的？还是说你已经完全走到了它的对立面，觉得完全不会？你知道的，变老其实挺有帮助的，因为人变懒了。你知道我的意思吗？
Like, I feel like it would take, it takes so much energy to be like scoring and then you got to meet the guy on the side of the road and he's standing on the corner and I'm meeting you, now you're showing out, now it's in the morning, you know, I mean, like some cash from the ATM, it's just, yeah, it's a lot of ATM shenanigans and I just, I don't know if I've got it like that anymore. But I would say that, you know, for sure it is sort of like core to a DNA or whatever that I, that I have on both sides of the coin, you know, whether that's like the darkness of it or, or the, the lightness of sort of emerging from that and seeing life through
就像，我觉得这需要，这需要耗费太多的精力去搞到毒品，然后你还得去路边跟那个人见面，他站在街角，然后我去见你，现在你在炫耀，现在已经是早上了，你知道的，我的意思是，从自动取款机取点现金，这简直是，是的，有太多的自动取款机把戏了，而我不知道我是否还有那种精力了。但我得说，你知道的，这绝对就像是某种核心DNA或者别的什么，我，我在这枚硬币的两面都有过体验，你知道，无论是那种黑暗，还是那种从黑暗中走出来、通过
a greater, you know, perspective or, you know, a prism of sort of gratitude or something. But it's, it's also like helpful in, in weird situations, like, I don't know if you guys who have any experience with this find that like, I'm not much moved by something like night shoots or something, you know, like I'll see a lot of people that are walking around me like, oh my God, it's so crazy. It's like 3am. I'm like, who am I? You know?
更广阔的视角来看待生活的轻松感，或者说是一种感恩的棱镜之类的。但这，在某些奇怪的情况下也挺有帮助的，比如，我不知道你们是否有过这种经验，就是我对夜戏之类的事情其实没什么感觉，你知道的，我看到周围有很多人走来走去，说：哦天哪，太疯狂了。都凌晨3点了。我会想：我是谁？你知道吗？
And I'm like, who am I? I've always been the caretaker, you know what I mean? 3am is my home. I'm the opposite. I'm like, if I'm driving home with the sun coming up, this is usually a bad sign. Yeah. And so I don't like night shoots. Reminds me of the old days.
然后我会想：我是谁？我一直都是那个照顾别人的人，你知道我的意思吗？凌晨3点是我的主场。我恰恰相反。我会觉得如果我在日出时开车回家，这通常是个不好的征兆。是的。所以我不喜欢夜戏。这让我想起了从前的日子。
Yeah. But what about addiction? Like, like I'm, I'll always be an addict. I've just managed to channel that into something much less hurtful, much more productive, much more upstanding. Do you mean just pure workaholism? Yeah. Cause yeah, I'm like now, and when people are like, oh my God, how do you do it?
是的。但是成瘾呢？比如，我，我将永远是一个瘾君子。我只是设法把那种冲动引导到了伤害小得多、生产力高得多、也正派得多的方向上。你是说纯粹的工作狂吗？是的。因为，是的，我现在这样，当人们说：哦天哪，你是怎么做到的？
You're like a writer, director, showrunner, you're acting and you're like, well, it's on one job and I'm, and obsessive. I mean, it's another way of being like, and you got the company and you got like 19 shows and you want to direct three movies and how are you going to do all that? And it's like, well, you know, how did I, you know, smoke all that dust? That was not my problem. PCP was not my problem. Sure.
你既是编剧、导演、剧集运作人，你还在演戏，然后你会觉得，嗯，这只是一份工作，而且我是，而且我很痴迷。我的意思是，这是另一种生活方式，而且你还有公司，你手头有19个节目，你想导演三部电影，你打算怎么做到这一切？这就好比，嗯，你知道的，我是怎么，你知道的，吸了那么多尘土？那不是我的问题。PCP（天使尘）不是我的问题。当然。
Sure. You know what? I'd love to be able to say smoke and dust. How was your weekend? Mainly smoke and dust. I was so fucking dusted this weekend. I love, I wish I had smoked dust. And I read, I read along.
当然。你知道吗？我真希望能说出“吸尘土”这种话。你周末过得怎么样？主要是吸尘土。我这周末真是他妈的嗨大了。我喜欢，我真希望我抽过天使尘。而且我读过，我一直在读。
They say smoke and dust is not a relapse. Oscar LeVance said that. Yeah. It's not LeVance. That's Ed Eaton ain't cheating. That was LeVance. Ed Eaton ain't cheating. Yeah.
他们说抽天使尘不算复吸。奥斯卡·莱万特说过这个。是的。不是莱万特说的。那是，埃德·伊顿说作弊不算。那是莱万特说的。埃德·伊顿说作弊不算。是的。
But you know what? I love Natasha is the ease. I don't know. There's something about the way that you deal with and talk about that. Time in your life, because I don't want to spend too much time on it, but I know, look, I always think about it from my experiences. I needed contrast and it's been a lifelong thing for me of dealing with that contrast and going through those times.
但你知道吗？我喜欢娜塔莎的这种从容。我不知道。你对待和谈论那段生活的方式有一种特别的魅力，因为我不想在这上面花太多时间，但我知道，听着，我总是从自己的经历出发来思考这个问题。我需要对比，处理这种对比并经历那些时光一直是我毕生的功课。
Again, I don't prescribe it for anybody. But sort of coming out the other end of it, it does give you, I don't know, perspective and I've had so much perspective. And I've been the beneficiary of so many people's so much kindness and so many other people have been really helpful and great people in my life. And it's given me now as I'm 52, such a different appreciation for life and appreciation for my kids and appreciation for the people I love. And it gives me such a great, better approach to life day to day.
再次说明，我不向任何人推荐这种经历。但从另一端走出来之后，它确实赋予了你，我不知道，视角，我拥有了如此多的视角。我受益于许多人的巨大善意，生命中也有过那么多真正乐于助人、非常棒的人。现在我52岁了，这让我对生活有了完全不同的感激之情，对我的孩子们有了感激之情，对所爱的人有了感激之情。这让我的日常生活有了一种更好、更棒的态度。
I don't sweat the small stuff in ways that I used to. I don't, all that kind of shit, I'm just, I don't know, I wake up every day. I don't know about you. I wake up every day and I'm like, boy, I'm happy. It's a nice day out today. Boy, I'm lucky. I'm having this cup of coffee. Boy, I got to suck back six cigarettes while I'm doing my little, you know what I mean?
我不再像过去那样为什么小事而焦虑了。我不会，所有那些破事，我只是，我不知道，我每天醒来。我不知道你们怎么样。我每天醒来都会想：天哪，我很开心。今天天气真好。天哪我很幸运。我正在喝这杯咖啡。天哪，我得在做我那点事的时候连抽六根烟，你知道我的意思吗？
The beautiful thing. Well, you can't, you definitely, I would say, you know, first of all, I mean, I'm transparent about it. Well, one aspect of it is I have no choice, right? Like in other words, it's out there. I guess I was lucky that it wasn't in a cell phone era. So there's not too many crazy pictures, but you know, it was definitely same news. And I didn't hear it.
美好的事物。嗯，你绝对不能，我会说，你知道的，首先，我的意思是，我对这事很坦诚。其中一个方面是，我别无选择，对吧？换句话说，事情就摆在那儿。我想我很幸运，那不是智能手机的时代。所以没有太多疯狂的照片，但你知道的，这绝对是同样的旧闻。而且我没听说过。
It's news to me on this. And I gobble up a bunch of pop culture. You don't fucking follow me. You should read some of like the post from the 90s. I feel like it's going to backlog. Microfiche. You'll find it. Microfiche.
这对我来说是个新鲜事。我吸收了大量的流行文化。你根本不关注我。你应该去读读90年代的那些报道。我觉得这可以列入后台档案。缩微胶卷。你能找到的。缩微胶卷。
Amanda, his wife, who you might know, complained to me the other day at how little you pay attention to what's going on. Well, no, but I was, because I'm busy watching the news. You're not watching the news. But I think more than that, it's, there's an opportunity there, you know, in the transparency, which makes you sort of like, I always feel like I have this sort of duty in a way to my inner child for lack of a better term, which is really like she wants to, she very badly wants to tell the truth.
阿曼达，他的妻子，你可能认识，前几天向我抱怨，说你对周围发生的事情是多么的不关注。好吧，不，但是我是，因为我忙着看新闻。你才没看新闻呢。但我认为更重要的是，这里面有一个机会，你知道的，在坦诚之中，这让你觉得，我总是觉得我以某种方式对我的内在小孩负有一种责任，借用一个更好的词来形容，那就是她想要，她非常渴望说出真相。
Like she, she really is like hell bent on integrity and good times and hanging out. And it is sort of like a misfit and lawless. And I have to kind of like wrangle her and make her do adult stuff. Like, and, but mostly she just doesn't understand. And I would say I have this very much in common with Charlie this character from poker face. Like doesn't understand the point of lying since we all die. Like John Lennon says, just give me some truth, you know, and really doesn't understand why the setup or the conceit of life is about, you know, small talk and being fake and lying
就像她，她真的对正直、好时光和聚会有一种近乎顽固的执着。而且她有点像个格格不入的法外之徒。我不得不像这样管束她，让她去做成年人的事。而且，但大部分时间她只是不理解。而且我想说，我和《扑克脸》里的这个角色查理有着极大的共同点——那就是不理解说谎的意义，既然我们终将一死。正如约翰·列侬所说，只要给我一点真相，你知道的，真的不理解为什么生活的设定或构思是关于闲聊、虚伪以及
about how well you're doing. Like there's nothing inherently embarrassing about life being a double-edged sword. And, you know, the buy-in of the game is we all die in the end. And that's a super head trip and the whole time you're supposed to be sort of ambitious and involved in this rat race and watching out for your health. And, you know, you see bodies piling up of, you know, people, suicide rates or whatever. It's just, it's hard to kind of make sense of the riddle of the game. And addiction certainly helps you to understand that like every person, I mean, it's one of
谎称自己过得有多好。生活是一把双刃剑，这本身并没有什么好尴尬的。而且，这个游戏的买入筹码就是我们最终都会死。这是一个超级震撼的精神体验，而在整个过程中，你本该雄心勃勃地参与到这场激烈的竞争中，注意自己的健康。而且，你知道的，你看到身边的尸体堆积如山，自杀率等等。这实在很难让人去理解这个游戏谜题的意义。而毒品确实能帮你理解这一点，每个人，我的意思是，这是演艺圈最黑暗的部分之一，
the darkest parts of showbiz is, you know, the solipsism that comes with people thinking they're the center of the universe, so like that revelation of getting clean is that's the big one, right? And you start to see that everybody is a real person who's going through all their own little micro dramas and darkness and all this stuff. So I don't know, just globally, to me, it feels like transparency is a sort of, you may as well, because what's the difference? Like there's such a better chance of helping.
就是人们以为自己是宇宙中心的这种唯我独尊，所以戒毒带来的那种觉悟就是最大的觉悟，对吧？你开始看到每个人都是一个真实的人，都在经历着他们自己的微小戏剧和黑暗以及所有这些事情。所以，我不知道，总的来说，对我而言，坦诚感觉像是一种，你不如就直说好了，因为有什么区别呢？因为这样更有可能去帮助别人。
Well, I think the only problem is you run the risk of, because people have sensationalism and click feed and bait and all that kind of stuff that they want to take, boil what you say and your views on stuff and boil it down to, I remember once when I was very honest about the fact that I had relapsed, you know, I say relapsed, but whatever that means to people. When I had gone out and I've been drinking and there was like a, you know, all of a sudden like the Daily Mail, like Will Arnett admits that he hit the bottle. Why did he fucking hit the bottle?
嗯，我认为唯一的风险是，你会冒这样的风险，因为人们喜欢哗众取宠、点击诱饵和所有那些他们想要利用的东西，他们会把你所说的话和你的观点断章取义，简化成——我记得有一次，我很坦诚地承认我复吸了，你知道的，我说复吸，但不管这对人们意味着什么。当我出去喝了酒，突然之间，就像《每日邮报》那样：威尔·阿奈特承认他借酒浇愁。他他妈为什么要借酒浇愁？
You know, he's like, and that's, and then it was picked up a bunch of different stuff. And so then somebody else is like, Hey, you don't want to talk about it anymore. We go, not really because every time I do, like it fucking smacks me in the face because somebody writes some snarky fucking one line click thing. So it's like, yeah, but that's, that's the media's agenda, you know, and you, that's their business is none of our business. But what I sense from, from you, Will and from you, Natasha, and I try to do is, is do exactly what you're talking about, Natasha, which is be mindful of that, that little kid
你知道的，他就像是，然后这被很多不同的东西转载了。然后其他人就会说，嘿，你不想再谈这个了吗？我们回答，其实并不想，因为每当我谈起它，就像它他妈的狠狠抽了我一巴掌，因为总有人写一些尖酸刻薄的、为了点击率的混蛋标题。所以这就变成，嗯，但那是媒体的议程，你知道的，那是他们的生意，跟我们没关系。但我从你身上，威尔，还有从你身上，娜塔莎，以及我试图做的事情中感受到的是，恰恰就是娜塔莎你所谈论的，那就是时刻保持正念，去关照那个
that's still in all of us. And if you are, if you're honest with that little kid and you give that little kid the sort of the agency that that kid deserves in your life, you know, that presence in your life and you don't try to, you know, work on some veneer or some artifice that keeps that little kid hidden in and instead let that kid be a part of your, your decisions and your behavior every single day, then you're not asking people to buy a bunch of shit that you can't sell real good, you know, you're just being honest and being you and being the only you.
依然存在于我们所有人心中的那个小孩子。如果你，如果你对那个小孩子保持诚实，并赋予那个小孩子在你的生活中应得的代理权，你知道的，那种在你的生活中占据一席之位，而不是试图去伪装某种外表或虚假的人设来把那个小孩子藏起来，相反，让那个小孩子参与到你每天的决定和行为中，那么你就不需要去向人们兜售那些你根本卖不好的狗屁倒灶，你知道的，你只是在做真实的自己，做独一无二的你。
There's only one Natasha. I think, I think that's right. Natasha, do you, I was thinking about this last night. Do you have, I think that there's great power in being vulnerable or being open. It's the only way we can be funny. All four of us are funny. Like that you can't, there's nothing funny about somebody who's bulletproof. Like it's all about, you know, warts and all.
只有一个娜塔莎。我想，我想这是对的。娜塔莎，你，我昨晚一直在想这个。你觉得，我認為展现脆弱或敞开心扉具有巨大的力量。这是我们能变得好笑的唯一途径。我们四个人都很搞笑。就像你不能，一个刀枪不入的人身上没有任何好笑的地方。这全都是关于，你知道的，无论优点还是缺点。
And, and because, you know, the, the, what you touched on Natasha about talking about we're all going to die. I think about that all the time and not in a morbid way, but it makes you become self. I bet your first, Sean, just saying it now makes you become self aware enough to do exactly what Will's about to say, which was become vulnerable. So if you're aware of your existence and you're soon to be non-existence, you know, it makes you go, like you said, like, who gives a shit about any of it?
而且，因为，你知道的，娜塔莎你刚才提到的，谈论我们终将一死。我一直在想这个，并不是以一种病态的方式，但它会让你变得自我。我敢打赌，肖恩，你现在说出来，就会让你变得足够有自我意识，从而去做出威尔接下来要说的那种举动，也就是变得脆弱。所以，如果你意识到了自己的存在以及即将到来的非存在，你知道的，这会让你觉得，就像你说的，谁他妈在乎那些破事呢？
Let it be open, be honest, be vulnerable. Tell people how you feel in the moment. And if it scares you, it's a way to overcome that fear of expressing your emotion. I think. Yeah. And I do definitely feel like that softening happening of like, I think it was so, I think I was, you know, so into kind of like tough guys as a kid growing up. That's probably why I have like this, you know, action or whatever.
敞开心扉，诚实一点，勇敢展现脆弱。随时告诉别人你的真实感受。如果这让你感到害怕，这也是一种克服表达情感之恐惧的方法，我觉得。是的。而且我确实绝对能感觉到那种软化的过程发生，我觉得这太，我觉得我，你知道的，小时候成长过程中太迷恋那种硬汉形象了。这可能就是为什么我有这种，你知道的，动作片情节或者别的什么。
I'd watch a Scarface or like Sylvester Stallone, Rocky, that's what I want to be. And like you were saying, De Niro. And I loved, you know, Betty Davis and Jessica Lange and whatever. But really I was like, those are my guys. And I think also in many ways I was using that as a way to sort of be safe in the world and say, hey, I'm not like this other game. And now over the years, even in even in talking about things like addiction, which is, it's just something that never goes away.
我会看《疤面煞星》或者西尔维斯特·史泰龙的《洛奇》，那才是我想要成为的人。就像你说的，德尼罗。我喜欢，你知道的，贝蒂·戴维斯、杰西卡·兰格或者别的什么。但实际上我是想，那些才是我的榜样。而且我也认为在很多方面我是在用这种方式来让自己在这个世界上感到安全，并说：嘿，我不像其他那些软弱的人。而现在这些年来，甚至在谈论成瘾这样的话题时，这仅仅是，这只是一种永不会消失的东西。
I mean, those are just like facts. There's nothing to really hide there. It'd be a scam to say otherwise. I do now feel this sort of softening happening where, yeah, it's just you may as well tell the truth because what else are you going to do when you may as well like, you know, when you say, I wake up and it's, it's a beautiful day and I'm grateful. It's like, you know, for sure, sometimes that takes me a second, but it's like the gift in a way is the experience or the familiarity with self to not take it too seriously anymore.
我的意思是，那些只是事实。没有什么好真正隐瞒的。否则说别的就是在自欺欺人了。我现在确实感受到了这种软化的发生，那就是，嗯，你不如说出真相，因为你还能做什么呢，你不如，你知道的，当你说道，我醒来，今天是个好日子，我很感激。这就好；你知道的，当然，有时这需要我花上一秒钟去调整，但这就好像是，这种经历或对自负的熟悉感带来的天赋，就是不再把它看得太重。
And kind of the whatever that sort of, I guess more like a Buddhist idea of watching the thoughts or something. So I'm more like, all right, I think it's a piece of shit day, but we're going to get up and like have some coffee. And I mean, it's really for me, the joy of comedy or like, you know, like spending this kind of life with Fred and Maya and Amy is like, just that sense of now we're laughing hysterically about a third thing. And in that space, it is an altered state.
以及某种类似于佛教思想中的“观察念头”之类的东西。所以我更多的是在想：好吧，我觉得今天是个狗屎天，但我们还是得起床去喝杯咖啡。我的意思是，对我来说，喜剧的乐趣，或者说，你知道的，像和弗雷德、玛雅、艾米一起度过这样的人生，就只是那种我们正在为第三件事疯狂大笑的感觉。而在那种空间里，那是一种改变了的精神状态。
And now I'm kind of, I've had a full mood shift where suddenly I'm stoked. And now I'm in the car driving and the sun is sort of, you know, music's playing. And I'm like, it's not that bad. Is it your new healthy drug? Jason, can I ask you a question? Do you find that you're sort of like before you start a season of Ozark, like for me with Russian dollars a little bit, like before I start to say, I'm like, and that's who I'm going to be and I'm going to wake up and I'm going to be excited about this cup of coffee.
而现在我差不多，我的情绪发生了完全的转变，突然之间我变得动力十足。现在我坐在车里开车，阳光正以某种方式，你知道的，音乐在播放。然后我会想：其实也没那么糟。这是你的新健康药物吗？杰森，我可以问你一个问题吗？你是否发现在你开始拍摄一季《黑钱胜地》之前，就像我对于《轮回派对》一样，在开始拍摄之前，我会想：这就是我要成为的人，我醒来时会对这杯咖啡感到兴奋。
I'm so great. I get to have this show and it's my baby and it's going to be great. And then the rush of sort of like almost like the thinking at that level and working yourself at that level in the writer's room and the like the pre-production and that you're really, you find yourself getting tight and it's not quite, it's not as easy as it was. Like you really have to set aside time to not buy into the fact that this sort of alternate reality, that sort of anxiety based, you know what I mean? Of just logistics in a way is because sometimes I find that I have to really like that's when
我太棒了。我能有这个节目，这是我的宝贝，它会非常棒。然后那种几乎就像是在那个层面上思考、在编剧室和前期制作中让自己在那个层面上高强度工作的冲动，会让你发现自己开始变得紧绷，事情并没有那么简单。就像你真的必须腾出时间来，不要去相信那种由焦虑驱动的交替现实，你知道我的意思吗？纯粹是因为后勤杂务，因为有时候我发现我真的必须——这就是
the rubber meets the road for me of, you know, did you find that? Yeah, there's a lot of logistics and nuts and bolts and blocking and tackling that goes into what up until you start work is just this pure, it just lives in your brain and it's going to be perfect. And there's the, I think it was Ben Stiller that made some analogy once that like starting a movie as a director is that the painting is perfect. And then all the way through the production and development, principal photography and then post, you're trying to, there's like this fungus that starts to come in from the,
对我来说见真章的时刻，你知道的，你有过这种发现吗？是的，在开拍之前，这里面包含了大量的后勤、细枝末节、排练和应对，在此之前，它只是纯粹的构想，它只存在于你的脑海中，而且它将是完美的。而且存在着，我想本·斯蒂勒曾经做过这样一个比喻，大意是作为导演开始拍摄一部电影，就好像这幅画是完美的。然后从制作、开发、主体拍摄一直到后期，你都在试图——有一层真菌开始从
from the, which we call it the frame of the picture. Yeah. And it starts to take over the picture and you got to just keep the fungus back from the, and if you can get, maybe you're done with, maybe there's 30% of the picture is infested with this fungus, you've done pretty good. And the fungus is probably a little bit more pejorative than what he meant, but it's, you bring in all these collaborative thoughts and oftentimes are better thoughts, but it changes your picture, it changes the painting and that doesn't deserve a false negative.
画框的边缘侵蚀进来。是的。它开始接管这幅画，你必须把这真菌挡在画面之外，如果你能做到，也许画面有30%被这种真菌侵蚀了，你也已经做得相当不错了。这里的“真菌”可能比他原本的意思稍微贬义了一点，但这就是，你引入了所有这些合作的想法，通常这些是更好的想法，但它改变了你的画面，它改变了这幅画，这不该得到一个虚假的负面评价。
It actually change in the picture is actually a good thing because that is the result of sort of this teamwork and this, it takes a village and let people contribute. I find that that's when I really like, I really, when I'm sort of with my friends in Costa Rica and we're surfing, I'm like, yeah, fucking a man, this is good. And I find that that's the most when I have to sort of reset and not sort of buy the lie of the mind that like, this is so real, the stakes are so high. And that's when like things are really, that's when I can almost, you know, when it's sort of that time is that sort of significant is when I really feel sort of all the kind of
事实上，画面上的改变其实是一件好事，因为那是团队合作以及“众人拾柴火焰高”、让每个人都参与其中的结果。我发现，每当我真正喜欢这样的时候，比如我和朋友们在哥斯达黎加冲浪，我就会想：“天哪，太棒了，这感觉真好。”我发现，每当这时，我就需要调整自己，不要轻信大脑制造的谎言，仿佛这一切都那么真实，赌注都那么高。而就在这个时候，当事情真正……当那种时刻变得如此重要时，我才会真正感觉到所有的那种
work on self or revelations or whatever, like I remember walking on set on Russian doll and it's scary. You know, season two COVID is so this like the COVID shit is very intense when you're the boss, right? Like it's scary anyway, but now you're responsible for so many people's health. And I remember at one point like walking onto the stage and they were like, hello, hello Natasha. And I walked down and do all the jobs, right?
自我剖析、顿悟之类的事情。我记得走上《轮回派对》的片场时，其实挺吓人的。你知道的，第二季正值疫情期间，当你当老板时，疫情这破事儿真的非常棘手，对吧？无论如何这都很吓人，但现在你要对那么多人的健康负责。我记得有一次，我走进片场，他们喊着：“你好，你好，娜塔莎。”然后我走过去，把所有工作都包揽了，对吧？
And I was like, holy shit, this is like exactly where I was supposed to be, you know, meaning despite all of that, all the other kind of like outside elements, it was so sure kind of in my bones. And like that's what I mean by like me and the kid were kind of happy. And then we were sort of delighted by the kind of anxiety. And I sort of like, I felt the road widen a little bit of, oh, that's right. This is like this fun crazy thing that like we get to do. It's not, you know, this is that thing that I really, really love doing.
当时我就想：“靠，这简直就是我命中注定该呆的地方，”我的意思是，尽管有这一切、所有其他类似的外界干扰，我的内心却无比笃定。这就是我所说的“我和那个孩子都挺快乐”。然后我们又为那种焦虑感到一丝欣喜。我甚至觉得前方的路稍微变宽了，心想：“哦，对了。这就是那件好玩又疯狂的事，是我们有机会去做的事。这不是……你知道的，这就是我真正、真正热爱去做的那件事。”
I mean, directing in general is a, it's a very joyous sport, I would say of it just feels so awake and alive in a way that sometimes I think when I'm only acting, like it's different on something like this, because, you know, Ryan and I have like a real partnership, meaning in many ways I think, or even I would say for us, show dogs was like the two of us were in it together, meaning on some level it's like a body of work where it becomes the collaborator is what matters because you feel like you're, you're in something together, you know. But yeah, sometimes with, if you're just like, you know, acting and you have no say, you can
我的意思是，总的来说，导演是一项非常快乐的运动，我会这么说。它给人的感觉是如此清醒和充满生气，有时我想，如果我只负责演戏的话——虽然做这种项目时感觉会不一样，因为，你知道的，瑞安和我有着真正的伙伴关系，在很多方面都是如此，或者甚至可以说是我们俩，像《妙笔生花》这部电影就是我们俩一起完成的，这意味着在某种程度上，它就像是一部作品，真正重要的是合作者，因为你会觉得自己和别人是一起在经历某些事情，你知道的。但有时如果你只是……你知道的，只是演戏而没有任何发言权，你就会
almost feel very far from like the center of the action and kind of, all right, so you're just going to tell me who's like a middle-aged person who's been doing this for 35 years, like, oh, should I come stand over there or something? You're concerned I'm going to go pee and maybe I'll never come back. I'll forget that we're shooting, you know, like, they're just so concerned all the time. Are you directing any of these poker faces? Oh yeah, I did one, I did one that's not, the last one we finished because of the schedule and everything, but it said, Nick Nolte, I got to direct Nick Nolte.
感觉自己离行动的中心非常遥远，然后心想：“好吧，所以你只是想告诉我，一个已经干了35年的中年人，‘哦，我是应该站到那边去还是怎么着？’你是不是担心我去撒尿然后就再也不回来了？你是不是忘了我们正在拍戏，你知道的，就像，他们总是那么担心。”你在导演《扑克脸》里的这些剧集吗？哦，是的，我导演了一集，有一集我没导演，那是我们最后完成的一集，因为档期和其他原因，不过那集有尼克·诺尔特，我居然能导演尼克·诺尔特。
Oh wow. Oh yes, and now there's a real troublemaker. Yeah. She was great. Was he responsive to your direction? Oh yes, and like, we had that thing that you were talking about, that like vulnerability that comes on the other side of darkness or whatever, which is we speak, like, we speak of the same Inge, you know.
哦，哇。哦，是的，现在那里来了一个真正的麻烦制造者。是的。她太棒了。他对你的导演有什么反馈吗？哦，是的，我们有那种你刚才谈到的默契，那种在经历了黑暗或别的什么之后产生的脆弱感，也就是说，我们有着共同的语言，你知道的。
That's great. We had a lot of fun together. That's cool. Oh my God, I love him. Yeah, he's so interesting. What a great actor. Yeah, I haven't thought about him in a minute about, I haven't seen him in a while. He's so glad that you got him to do this.
太棒了。我们在一起玩得很开心。太酷了。天哪，我太喜欢他了。是的，他太有趣了。多棒的演员啊。是的，我有一会儿没想起他了，我也有一段时间没见到他了。很高兴你能让他来出演这个。
That's going to be cool. Oh my God, he's so, like, that face is really addictive. That's why I mean by like, at the, you're standing at the monitor and like, you know, we use all these zoom guns on poker face, like little like Altman's slow zooms or whatever. Yeah. And you're just like standing at the monitor riveted just pushing in on Nolte and all he's doing is thinking, you're like, oh, that's a fucking actor. Like, you know, that's just the smallest like flicker and you're fascinated.
那肯定很酷。天哪，他那张脸真的太吸引人了。这就是我为什么说，当你站在监视器前，你知道的，我们在《扑克脸》里用了所有这些变焦镜头，就像罗伯特·奥特曼那种缓慢的变焦之类的。是的。你就站在监视器前，看得入神，镜头慢慢推向诺尔特，而他脑子里什么都没想，你就会想：“哦，这他妈才叫演员。”就像，你知道的，只是最微小的眼神闪烁，你就会被迷住。
Like how do I get inside of your face? I love you using the zoom to instead of the dolly push. It's such a different feel. It's, it's a, I just, I dork out on that. Yeah, that's a lot like Ryan. I guess, I guess it's a Stevie Edlin shot the pilot who does all the brick and looper and Star Wars and all the knives out glass onion with him. And yeah, it's a lot of that's like baked into the DNA of even a, you know, like the
就像我该如何走入你的内心？我太喜欢你用变焦镜头来代替轨道推镜头了。那种感觉太不一样了。这是……我就是对这种技术着迷。是的，这很像瑞安。我想，我想是史蒂夫·埃德林拍摄了试播集，他拍过所有的《砖家》、《环形使者》、《星球大战》，还有雷恩·约翰逊的《利刃出鞘：抽丝剥茧》。是的，很多这种风格都融入到了……甚至可以说是，你知道的，
Colombo pilot that Spielberg did with like that's got that long shot down to the road. Wow. Yeah. I was just thinking about how do I, how do I get inside your face? And that's obviously what the sodium said to you, Jason, last night. Yeah. But it did. It got there.
斯皮尔伯格拍的《神探可伦坡》试播集里那种顺着公路的长镜头。哇。是的。我刚才还在想，我该如何，我该如何走进你的脸？显然，这就是昨天索迪姆对你说的，杰森。是的。但确实做到了。成功了。没有任何阻力。成功了。大门完全敞开了。娜塔莎，如果你的余生只能做导演而不再演戏，或者你只想两者都做一点，你会觉得快乐吗？我的意思是，我觉得可以。我绝对有那种进入“西德尼·波拉克时代”的想法，你知道的，就像库布里克
No resistance for me. It got there. It got there. The door was wide open. Natasha, would you, would you be happy if you did nothing but direct the rest of your career as opposed to act or you want to do a little of each? I mean, I, I think so. I'm definitely like wanting to be in my Cine Pollock era where, you know, like Kubrick
打电话给你说：“嘿，来演个角色吧，”是的，“来演个《大开眼戒》吧。”但大多数时候，我也觉得我们对这些家伙讨论得不够，比如西德尼·波拉克。所以我们只会想，你知道的，就像《窈窕淑男》那样，给自己安排一个绝佳的角色。没错。但是，那种……我真想成为那样的人。那简直就是我梦寐以求的理想状态。
calls you up and says, Hey, come be in, you know, yeah, come be an eyes wide shot. But mostly you're kind of also I like, I feel like we don't talk about those guys enough like the Cine Pollock. So we're just kind of like, you know, like Tootsie and just give yourself a great role in it. Exactly. But that, that kind of, I would like to be that guy. That's like my dream sweet spot.
没错。你刚才说……我刚刚出于不同的原因重温了这部电影，前天晚上我看了《夫妻们》的前半部分，波拉克、西德尼·波拉克就在里面。还记得吗？在第一个场景里他走进来，说他们要离婚了，他们要去处理一件事。他演得太棒了。还有别的事。
Right. And you say, I just watched for a different reason. I watched the first half of husbands and wives the other night in Pollock, Cine Pollock's in that. Remember he, in the first scene he comes in, he says they're getting divorced. They're going to go for a thing. He's so great. There was something else.
然后我就想到了他，还有《窈窕淑男》之类的事情。这家伙简直是个宝藏。不是吗？他拍了那么多集的《威尔和格蕾丝》。他扮演威尔的爸爸。他演得太棒了。西德尼·波拉克？是的。
And then I was thinking about him and Tootsie and stuff. And this guy is like, he's a fucking jam. Wasn't he? He did so many episodes of Will and Grace. He played Will's dad. He was great. Cine Pollock? Yeah.
太棒了。哇。那么你呢，娜塔莎？你客串过一集《威尔和格蕾丝》。我当然演过。费儒也经常把他自己安排在他拍的很多电影里。是的。乔恩挺喜欢演戏的。
It was fantastic. Wow. And so are you Natasha? You did an episode of Will and Grace. I sure did. Favreau puts himself in a lot of the movies he does too. Yeah. John likes a little acting.
乔恩·费儒。有点喜欢演戏。是的。我的意思是，我觉得这有点像是……我猜，你知道的，朗·霍华德在这方面也做得非常出色。不过我猜他现在不演了吧。他真的还演戏吗？不，他让克林特来演。
John Favreau. Little acting. Yeah. I mean, I think that's sort of, that's, I guess, you know, Ron Howard's done very nicely for himself. But I guess he doesn't. Does he really act at all? No, he puts Clinton in.
不。他让克林特代劳了。他让他弟弟来演。他自己就是不肯演。丹尼·德维托，你知道的，真的被严重低估了。我的意思是，他拍过不少重头电影。对，对，对。我知道。
No. He puts Clinton instead. He puts his brother in. He won't do it. Danny DeVito, you know, really underrated. I mean, he's made some major movies. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know.
克鲁尼自导自演，阿弗莱克自导自演。是的。杰基·贝茨。杰森·贝特曼自导自演。他太棒了。小杰基·贝茨。布莱德利。
Clooney directs himself, Affleck directs himself. Yeah. Yeah. Jackie Bates. Jason Bateman directs himself. He's amazing. Lil' Jackie Bates. Bradley.
想想布莱德利。是的。布莱德利拍了《音乐大师》，当然还有《一个明星的诞生》，那真是不可思议，现在他的新电影《音乐大师》更是绝佳之作。迫不及待了。你看过了吗？迫不及待想看了。太惊艳了。
Think about Bradley. Yeah. Bradley with Maestro, you know, obviously Star is Born Incredible and now his new film, Maestro, is off the chart. Can't wait. Have you seen it? Can't wait to see it. It's stunning.
是的。太惊艳了。太惊艳了。而且，他也做得非常出色，你知道的，每当他执导什么作品时，都感觉像是一件大事。所以他能和那么多优秀的人合作，而当他只是演戏时，你知道的，因为我觉得，我有一种理论——当我们在弥留之际回首往事时，
Yeah. It's amazing. It's amazing. Well, and also he's done such a, you know, great job that it feels like a real event when he's directing something. So it gets to work with so many great people and when he's just acting, you know, because I think, and I sort of have this theory that we're all going to look back as, you know, we're dying.
我们其实不会真正记得“在这部里我是导演，但在那部里我是执行制片人”这种事。所有围绕着它的虚荣心都会烟消云散，剩下的更像是我们和一起厮混的人共同创作的那些作品的片段，或者类似的东西。回到你刚才讨论的话题。这就好像是，是的，如果我余生只能和那些我真正喜欢合作的人以及我的朋友们一起工作，我也会觉得很开心。
We're not going to really remember kind of like in this one, I was the director, but this one, I was an executive producer. Like just all of that sort of sense of ego around it'll fall away and it'll be more like sort of like flashes of the things we made with the people we were hanging out with or something. Getting back to what you were talking about before. It's like, yeah, I'd be happy if I spent the rest of my life just working with the folks that I've really enjoyed working with and my friends.
我的意思是，我觉得我们已经积聚了一支相当庞大的队伍。你应该马上开始着手干这事。是的，但我确实。我太喜欢当导演了。这让我感到非常快乐。真的非常快乐。娜塔莎，我的意思是，我们已经比原定的一小时多聊了十分钟。
And I mean, I think we've accrued a nice big troop. You should start just getting going on that. Yeah, but I do. I love that directing. It makes me so happy. Yeah. It really does. Natasha, I mean, we've taken 10 more minutes than an hour.
这次采访我们要花在你身上的时间比平时采访别人要长了。是的。你刚才说过超过60分钟的话每分钟要付100美元。哇。那可是一千美元。分成三份。好吧，这虽然是个艰难的交易，但我很高兴你能来。我真的、真的很感激你答应来参加这个节目，娜塔莎。
That's going to cost us longer with you than we usually go with people. Yeah. You said $100 per minute over the 60. Wow. So that's a thousand bucks. Split that up three ways. Well, it was a tough deal, but I'm glad you came. I'm so, I'm so glad that you said yes to coming and doing this show Natasha.
老实说，我就是喜欢和你聊天，你真的是个很棒的人。谢谢你们。谢谢。我为你的所有成功感到高兴，我也为《扑克脸》感到非常高兴。等不及了。等等，它已经上映了还是快要上映了？已经上映了。所以现在已经可以看了。
I just honestly, I just love talking to you and you're such a great person. Thank you. Thank you. I'm so happy for all your success and I'm very happy about poker face. Can't wait. Wait, is it out or it's coming? It's out. So it's out now.
它在Peacock上播。真的挺不错的。我的意思是，瑞安很棒。瑞安·约翰逊的《扑克脸》正在流媒体平台上播出，在那个网站上，无论你从哪里能看到它，无论你从哪里能搞到你的“那个东西”，因为我不知道有些人是用Apple TV还是别的什么渠道，但不管怎样，这就是你通常能搞到“那个东西”的地方。这是一部很棒的流媒体剧集。我真的要变成奥斯卡·列凡特了。
It's on Peacock. It's really pretty great. I mean, Ryan is great. Ryan Johnson poker face on the streaming on the cock, wherever you can, wherever you get your cock, wherever you get your cock from, because I don't know some people use Apple TV or they get another thing, but whatever it is that you generally get your cock. This is a great stream coming out. I'm really coming to that Oscar Levant.
我现在就告诉你。我求之不得。快来看看。我们都要去首映式，那将是一个盛大的活动。绝对会不可思议。所以非常欢迎你来。一定要来。我们很乐意邀请你。
I'm telling you right now. I would love it. Come see. We're all going to the premiere, it's going to be a big event. It's going to be incredible. So you're welcome to come. Please do. We'd love to have you.
随时欢迎。好了，伙计们。谢谢。随时欢迎。在那个网站上。在那个网站上。好吧。谢谢你，娜塔莎。
Come anytime. All right, guys. Thank you. Come anytime. On the cock. On the cock. Okay. Thank you, Natasha.
莱昂。我们爱你。你是最棒的。谢谢。谢谢大家。非常感谢。再见。再见。
Leon. We love you. You're the greatest. Thank you. Thanks, guys. Thanks so much. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。所谓“重击离场”的意思就是，你直接合上笔记本电脑，结束T-Coup采访，而不是搞那种尴尬的客套，比如“好吧，所以……”就在刚说完再见、还没到最后时，他们就……是的。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. What's playing with slam means when you just shut the laptop and end the T-Coup interview instead of doing the awkward sort of like, okay, so. Right after saying goodbye, mid-atore they just yeah.
也许本尼特和罗布是在暗示他直接来个“重击离场”。而且最后我们也不需要跟他们进行什么后续交流，你知道的。是的，正好。我们刚好聊了一个小时。没错。我喜欢她的一点是，关于她，我最喜欢的是。她整个人完全敞开、毫不掩饰、对任何事情都泰然处之。
Maybe Bennet and Rob are giving him the heads up to go ahead do the slam thing. And we don't need we don't need follow-up at the end with them, you know. Yeah, exactly. We just had an hour. Right. Here's what I love about her by the way. I love that. She's, like completely open on apologetic comfortable about anything.
对任何事情都这样。她是个雷厉风行的人，伙计。我从来没有……我从来没跟她聊过天。我从来没跟她一起厮混过。不，我的意思是，我有过……我想我见过她几次。我想我跟艾米一起时见过她一次，当时她正在Netflix做《轮回派对》的项目。是的。是的。而且，呃，但这已经是我跟她最熟的时候了。是的。她和艾米。所以艾米和她一起制作了那个……《轮回派对》，娜塔莎是剧集运作人，艾米是制片人，获得了巨大的成功。他们是非常好的朋友。呃，但我们其实并没有……我知道，我的意思是，我稍微认识她一点，因为我和艾米是朋友，但我和她真正变成朋友是因为一起在海外拍那部儿童电影，呃，我们有很多
about anything. She's no nonsense, man. I've never, I've never talked to her. I've never hung out with her. No, I mean, I've, I've, I think I've met her a couple of times. I think I met her once with Amy when she was doing a Russian doll singing a Netflix thing. Yeah. Yeah. And, uh, but that's, that's, that's the most I've ever had. Yeah. She and Amy. So Amy produced, uh, um, that Russian doll with her that Natasha was the show and Amy produced it, a huge success. Uh, they're very good friends. Um, but we didn't really, I knew, I mean, I knew her a little bit just because she named me, we're friends, but she and I became friends going, doing this, that kids movie overseas and, uh, we had a lot of
欢乐，而且她是非常适合一起出国的那些绝佳人选之一，呃，因为她真的很有趣。是的。她简直是个开心果。她总能让你捧腹大笑。她看起来是最适合把“聪明笨蛋秀”带到欧洲巡演的人选……或许我们可以让她当个巡演助理。她一定会很乐意当个巡演助理的，就像是有史以来片酬最高的巡演助理。你觉得我今天的发型怎么样？我觉得真的很棒。是的。是的。看起来你就像是……呃，骑着摩托车在高速公路上狂飙过一样。再见。再见。再见。好吧，你是那个主动提起的人。我本来不该提的。好吧，我刚才往下查了查，感觉有点虎头蛇尾。好吧。我说了，迈克。聪明。聪明。
fun and she's one of those great people to be kind of out of the country with, uh, because she's really funny. Yeah. She's like, she's a riot. She just makes, makes you laugh. She seems like the best person to ever take smart lists on the road, uh, to Europe. Maybe we can make her a roadie. She'd love to be a roadie, like the highest paid roadie of all time. What do you think of my hair today? I think it's really great. Yeah. Yeah. It looks like you've been, um, riding at high speed on a motor. Bye. Bye. Bye. Well, you're the one to win up. I'm not supposed to go up. Well, I went down before and it felt like a fizzle. Okay. I said, Mike. Smart. Smart. Smart list is 100% organic and artisanally
“聪明笨蛋秀”100%有机，由罗布·麦克尔亨尼、本尼特·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工打造。聪明笨蛋秀。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，你可以在你听播客的任何地方收听，或者你也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上的Wondry plus或Wondry应用，抢先收听无广告版。《玩具总动员》是第一部完全采用计算机制作的动画长片，但它的天才之处不仅在于其开创性的图形技术，还在于其故事叙述。观众对巴斯光年和伍迪这两个角色的旅程产生了情感上的投入。皮克斯面临的赌注很高，因为一个新兴的动画竞争对手正在积蓄力量。梦工厂由创始人杰弗里·卡森伯格推动，他一心想向迪士尼首席执行官迈克尔·
handcrafted by Rob Armjolf, Bennett Barbaco and Michael Grant Terry. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. Toy Story was the first fully computer animated feature film, but its genius laid not in just its groundbreaking graphics, but also in its storytelling. Viewers became emotionally invested in the journey of the characters buzz and Woody. The stakes were high for Pixar because a new rival animation studio was gathering strength. DreamWorks was fueled by founder Jeffrey Katzenberg's quest for revenge against Disney CEO Michael
艾斯纳复仇。但渴望复仇的不止卡森伯格一人。皮克斯的史蒂夫·乔布斯也想智胜艾斯纳和他的魔法王国。嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondry节目《商业之战》的主持人。我们将深入探讨史上一些规模最大的企业竞争，在我们的最新系列节目中，皮克斯不仅要应对好莱坞的新星梦工厂，还要应对迪士尼对更多控制权的渴望。请在各大播客平台关注《商业之战》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondry应用上收听无广告版。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Eisner. But Katzenberg's not alone in his desire for retribution. Pixar's Steve Jobs also wants to outmaneuver Eisner and his magic kingdom. Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wondry show business wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time and in our latest series, Pixar has to contend not only with DreamWorks, the new kid in Hollywood, but with Disney's hunger for more control. Follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad free on the Amazon music or Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
埃斯纳。但渴望复仇的不止卡森伯格。皮克斯的史蒂夫·乔布斯也想智胜埃斯纳和他的魔法王国。嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondry商业战争节目的主持人。我们将深入探讨历史上一些最大的企业竞争，在我们最新的系列节目中，皮克斯不仅要应对好莱坞新秀梦工厂的挑战，还要应对迪士尼对更多控制权的渴望。请在各大播客平台关注商业战争。您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondry应用上收听无广告版。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。